THE COMMITTEE WILL COME
TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COPA NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WE ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITOL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ARE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
BE RECOGNIZE THAT YOU USE
THE RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP
UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING OUR I.
T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE WHEN YOUR DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCE
HE REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW THE NUMBER
FOR TODAY IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE
TWO AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
ONE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES
TO WORKS PLEASE REFER TO
THE SENATE AND R.
COMMITTEE WEBSITE PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY UNTIL FOR TO COOK
OF AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE YOUR
CONNECTION MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS OR
JUSTIN TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD THIS IS OUR FINAL
YES OUR FINAL SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER FIVE HEARING AND
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE EIGHT
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY JUDICIARY LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION ITEMS ALL VOTES
WILL BE TAKEN ONCE WE HAVE
COMPLETED PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN
AFTER PUBLIC COMMENT IS WHEN
WE WILL CONDUCT THE VOTE BEFORE
WE BEGIN WE MUST ESTABLISH A
QUORUM DR FRANCIS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATOR RAZA HERE RAZA
EARLIER SENATOR GROWTH SENATOR
CORTEZ HE YOUR SENATOR CORTEZ
HERE CONCERN NEWMAN SENATOR
NEWMAN HERE WE WE HAVE QUORUM
OKAY THE
WE'RE GOING TO START OF
-- WANTING OUT WITH ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS ON
THE VOTE ONLY PARTS OF THE
AGENDA AGAIN AS A REMINDER
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE ONE
SEVEN FOUR SEVEN SEVEN ONE DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS WE OF THE CHAIR
MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENT PLEASE
KEEP YOUR REMARKS TO UNDER ONE
MINUTE ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE ARE -- TAKING UP FOR VOTE
TODAY HAVE BEEN TAKEN UP IN
OUR PRIOR HEARINGS WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT OPPORTUNITY NOW THE
LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
HEARING NONE SEE NON -- WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME OPERATOR WILL ASSIST YOU
APPLYING PLACE BACK IN THE
QUEUE AMBER SO GO TO HE SAID
I'M SORRY MARTYR CAN YOU PLEASE
GIVE US THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY SURE
WE ARE PARTIALLY FIFTEEN
THANK YOU MODERATE -- YOU
CAN OPEN UP THE LINES AND
CALL THE MEMBERS TO SPEAK
I PERSONALLY GO TO LINE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE LINE TWENTY
SIX ALIGN IS OPEN
EGGMAN ONTO LINE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL SANCHEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS I'D LIKE
TO COMMENT REGARDING THAT
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDATION ON AT
SIX SEVENTY EIGHT CRITICAL BALK
AT SEVENTY EIGHT REPRESENT A
VERY SUCCESSFUL STATE REFORM
BY SUPPORTING ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION AS WE TALK ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF DATA THE
PROGRAM HAS A DECADE OF DATA TO
SHOW REDUCE PRISON POPULATIONS
LEADING TO THE STATE OF OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS IN AN ACCIDENT
I WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT
THE STABILITY IN THIS PROGRAM
DIRECTLY TRANSLATE TO KEEP THE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
OUT OF THE ITEM WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
TO DEVELOP A LONGER TERM COACH
TO KEEPING AT THE SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT A REFLECT ALL TURN IT
INTO A COPY AND THEN APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATORS HISTORICAL
SUPPORT OF THE PROGRAM I
DON'T FEEL LIKE TO BRIEFLY
COMMENT ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND EXISTING
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PRE TRIAL
PROGRAM TO MAKE IT STATEWIDE
WHICH IS MISS COMMITTEE HAS
DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY I WOULD
I TO STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK THAT
CREEK STANDARD AND GOT AND
OTHER FACTORS PARTICULARLY
FOLLOWING THE HUMPHREY
DECISION THERE'S LIKELY TO BE
A DIFFERENT APPLICATION IN THE
PRE TRIAL WHAT IS NEEDED IS A
UNIFIED APPROACH TO PRE TRIAL
IMPLEMENTATION THAT SUPPORT
THEIR FAITH AND EQUITABLE
ADMINISTRATION OBJECTIVE AGAIN
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
AND ITEMS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
CAN TELL EXACTLY DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING EIGHTY
FIVE TRANSMITTAL AGENCIES
ARE STATE SPEAKING TODAY ON
ISSUES ONE AND TWO ON ISSUE ONE
RELATED TO THE TRANSPORTATION
DEVELOPMENT ACT THE LANGUAGE
WE WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO APPROVE THE PLACEHOLDER
TRIBAL LANGUAGE I HAD SPOKEN
TO A COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHILE
ENCOURAGING -- THE LEGISLATURE
TO PROVIDE RELIEF CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT AGENCY THROUGH CRITICAL
YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
CERTAINLY THE OUTLOOK FOR
PUBLIC TRANSIT AGENCY IS MUCH
IMPROVED FROM THE NATURE THAT
WE CREATE LAST YEAR GROUP WE
ARE NOT YET OUT OF THE WOODS
ON THE ISSUE TO REWARD URGE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO PROVE
THE FULL SUITE OF INVESTMENT
IN THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL
OFFERED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
OPT FOR OUT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF KEY INVESTMENTS
THAT WILL DRIVE SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION BOARD I
ENSURING THAT WE CAN BUILD
CAPACITY ARE DELIVERED GOOD
CLEAN JOB HI AN ALTERNATELY
PROVIDE GREATER ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIANS OKAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS A DEADLINE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS WILL
BE RIGHT WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF I WANTED
TO POINT OUT THAT WE SUPPORT
ITEM TO -- AND THE FOCUS -- FOR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
ON ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION AND
TRANSIT EXPANSION WITHIN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE --
WE WOULD AGREE THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE FULL SUITE
OF PROGRAMS IN THIS -- ITEM
CARRIED FORWARD AND RATHER
THAN DELAYING ACTION ON THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
COMPONENTS WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE
-- OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM THE LAST
THING I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
-- WAS WITHIN ITEM THIRTY FIVE
AND THAT THE NEED FOR -- THE
INVESTMENT THERE IN THE DMV IS
-- UPDATING OF THEIR SYSTEMS
TO IMPLEMENT THE SMOG CHECK
TRUCKS -- IT'S MANTECH PROGRAM
FOR HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS THAT WAS
AUTHORIZED UNDER S.
B.
TWO TEN -- SO ESSENTIALLY
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF ITEM TO AND WANT
TO SEE THAT EXPANDED AND
THEN ALSO -- MOVING FORWARD
WITH ITEM THIRTY FIVE TO
IMPLEMENT THE CRITICAL SMOG
CHECK FOR TRUCK DIESEL TRUCKS
PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH THAT'S WHAT COMPUTER'S ID
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS --
-- SPEAKING ON ISSUE THIRTEEN
THE PSYCHIATRIC INPATIENT
PROGRAM AND -- INTEGRATION
STANDARDIZATION PROPOSALS ON
A REVISED -- THIS PROPOSAL
REPRESENTING MAJOR POLICY
SHIFT FROM THE WAY C.
D.
C.
R.
OPERATES THEIR PET PROGRAMS
AND WE STRONGLY RECOMMEND
THAT THE DEPARTMENT REJECT
THIS PROPOSAL AND GIVE BE A
POLL THE COMMITTEE THE FULL
OPPORTUNITY TO THAT THIS
PROPOSAL THROUGH THE JANUARY
BUDGET THANK YOU WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT WE GO TO LINE SIXTY
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME MIGUEL GARCIA WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF EIGHT ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE APPROVAL OF
THIRTY MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND TO ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
AND ADOPT A PROVISIONAL BUDGET
LANGUAGE AND A PLACEHOLDER
LANGUAGE THE LANGUAGE -- TO
CLARIFY THE FUNCTION DOUBLE
WIDE YEAH THE CLOSURE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
AND LINGERED AND CONTINUES
TO LOOK FORWARD ON WE BELIEVE
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DEVELOP AN AGENCY BASED ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SEPARATE
PLANS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MAKE SURE THAT THE LINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HI
MY NAME IS MARC WATTS I'M
CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS METROLINK IN THE
PLASTIC KIND TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AGENCY PROBABLY HAPPEN
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA
I'M SPEAKING ON ART OF NUMBER
TWO -- ITEM NUMBER TWO IS THE
MAY REVISION TRANSPORTATION
PROPOSALS WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH A COALITION OF RELATED
INDUSTRY MEMBERS AND OTHER
PARTNERS AND WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSALS AS PROPER BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM FOLLOW STATE AND FEDERAL
REVENUE RESOURCES THAT HAVE
I'VE BEEN MADE AVAILABLE
REPRESENTS A ONCE IN A LIFETIME
INVESTMENT INTO MULTI MODAL
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS AS I
INDICATED WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH A COALITION OF MEMBERS
WE ALSO BEEN WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATORS AND BOTH HOUSES
THAT HAVE -- GREED TO -- MARCH
THE PROGRAM WE ARE OFFERING WE
THINK THAT -- SUPPLEMENTING --
SOME OF THE -- HE COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAMS LIKE S.
U.
T.
P.
TCP HEPA AND GLORY AND HAVING
THE GREAT SEPARATION IT IS
A IMPORTANT AND MAKING OF
THOSE PROGRAMS AVAILABLE TO
CITIES COUNTIES ORIGINALLY
THANK PARTISAN IS KEY
BECAUSE THEY'RE REGULARLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED GREAT R.
JOINT REQUEST MAY ALSO TARGET
IS REDUCTION OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION PROGRAMS INCLUDING
MORE FUNDING FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AN INCREASE IN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS AND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
IG ORGANIZATIONAL HOUSING
THANK YOU MA'AM I'M SORRY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR CALLING I APPRECIATE IT
MEXICO TO LINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD SH HELLO THIS
IS MONEY CALLING MOTHER I'M NOT
QUITE SURE TO FIGHT INTERPRETER
AND I NEED YOUR TICKET -- AGAIN
IN A POSITION INTERPRETING
EVERY MOST EVERYTHING ELSE MOST
PEOPLE DO NOT HAVE THE MEANS
TO USE THE TECHNOLOGY NECESSARY
TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING AID TECHNOLOGY
ADOPTED SO FAR ANYTHING LIKE
AND LIKE EITHER TYPE OF LAST
MINUTE IN ADDITION COMBINATION
OF TECHNOLOGY FOR THE RADIO
BUT PROBLEM IDENTIFICATION
MAKING PEOPLE WANT TO TALK TO
THE UNION SELECT THE CORRECT
TECHNOLOGY THE CLERK WILL
PROVIDE THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
POLICE ARE WITH THE MEANS TO
ACCESS THESE HEARING NOT A G.
R.
IT COULD BE CONSIDERED AT THE
WAITING IT'S BEEN DONE IT'S
REALLY ALL ABOUT IT I THANK
YOU PLEASE DO NOT PASS THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR CALLING THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ANOTHER INTERPRETER
AND I WILL BE BRIEF WITHOUT
REFERRING TO SPECIFIC ASPECTS
OF LEGISLATION NUMBER ONE THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS THREATENING
TO DISALLOW CERTIFIED COURT
INTERPRETER LIKE MYSELF AND
THE LAST SPEAKER IT CHARGES
LAST RATE I REPRESENT DISTRICT
WHERE INTERPRETERS MUST WORK AS
CONTRACTORS A AND B.
NEED TO THE BUDGET SURPLUS
JUST FIND THE LACK OF ACCESS
TO JUSTICE IF THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA WHO NEEDED IN
SPANISH WILL HAVE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS ON THE COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR A USING
A BUDGET SURPLUS TO FUND THE
COUNTY COURT AND B.
YEAH I NEED YOU TO SPELL THAT
WE NEED TO GET THE CHARGE FLAT
RATE AND I ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE LOUDSPEAKER A LIMITED
VERY LIMITED USE OF REMOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT WE GO TO LINE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS DOMINIQUE
NON ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF OVER THIRTY
FIVE MEMBER ORGANIZATION THAT
THE STATEWIDE CALIFORNIA NINE
BUT YOU THINK YOU MEAN DO JUST
THAT WHO ARE ALWAYS STRONG
SUPPORT THE SENATE PROPOSAL
IN ITEM FIFTY SEVEN TO FIND
THE OPPOSITE YOU CAN COMMUNITY
RESTORATION AT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND HAVE CONTINUED
DELIBERATIONS ON TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE PHOTO NEEDED TO
PROPEL THE LEGISLATURE MISSION
AND VISION FOR HOW WE TRULY
SUPPORT THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH NEW YOUR
STAFFING ADMINISTRATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT WE GO TO LINE EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD HI GOOD
AFTERNOON AMONG THEM ANOTHER
PROTECTED BY THE SPANISH
INTERPRETER YES TO OPPOSE THE
REMOTE -- HEARINGS ON PROPOSED
PROPOSAL BECAUSE HE HAS TOO
MANY THINGS HAPPENING WITH
THE TECHNOLOGY WILL GET A
LITTLE CONSTRUCTION BOCANEGRA
SOMEONE INTERCEPTING ANYBODY
HURT HOW TO MAKE AN ACCURATE
INTERPRETATION WHEN USING
GETTING A TECHNOLOGY AND
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THANK YOU WE GO TO LINE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
THIS IS ALMA ROBINSON FROM
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS FOR THE
ARTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
I HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME I AM
SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF INCREASED
VISITATION WHICH IS IN EUROPE
-- NUMBER ELEVEN AND ALSO
INCREASING TECHNOLOGY FOR
PEOPLE AN EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
NUMBER SIX AND LOOKING AHEAD
TO THE POSSIBLE REPLACEMENT OF
THE LANGUAGE IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION THAT NOW ACCEPT
-- THE ABOLITION OF INVOLUNTARY
SLAVERY SERVITUDE FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE SERVING TIME FOR
CRIMES FOR PUNISHMENT OF THE
CRIME I'M HOPING THAT YOU CAN
START TO CONSIDER HOW TO PAY
PRISONERS FOR WORK PERFORMED
FOR THE GOVERNMENT OR TRIP
PRIVATE INDUSTRY GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR ATTENTION THANK YOU FOR
REACHING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF ARTS IN CORRECTIONS
PROGRAMS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YES REGUL R.
CITY OF THE LORD DR DO
I MY VOICE BONTA BURKE
THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK NEXT WE GO
TO LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS IN IS HORRIBLY I'M ON THE
COURT CERTIFIED INTERPRETER
IN THE LOS ANGELES SUPERIOR
COURT I'M CALLING TO SPEAK
AGAINST REMOTE COURT HEARINGS
-- DEFENDANTS ARE UNABLE TO
HAVE ANY PRIVATE CONVERSATION
WITH THEIR ATTORNEYS WHEN
THE INTERPRETATION IS DONE
REMOTELY AND -- IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT OF THE THE
INTERPRETER IS IN THE COURTROOM
WITH THE DEFENDANT AND THE
DEFENSE ATTORNEY THANK YOU
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME
NEXT THIRTY NINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M SORRY
MY NAME IS MARIA CRUZ I'M AN
EMPLOYEE OF SANTA CLARA I AM
CERTIFIED SPANISH INTERPRETER
I WANTED TO KINGCOME ADAM CHAIR
AND THE MEMBERS BUT WE HAVE
GREAT DIFFICULTY WITH THE WAY
THAT REMOTE INTERPRETING IS
CURRENTLY BEING IMPLEMENTED FOR
EXAMPLE MY COURT YOU SIXTEEN
BUT LET'S SAY THAT I NEEDED
TO DO REMOTE INTERPRETING
TO HUMBOLDT THEY MIGHT HAVE
SEEN OR SOON OR SOME OTHER
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD MAKE IT AT
PASSABLE FOR ME TO INTERPRET
FOR HUMBOLDT SO IF WE ARE TO
USE REMOTE INTERPRETING THE
COURTS NEED TO UPGRADE TO THE
PROPER TECHNOLOGY AND EVERY
COURT IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
YOUR PLATFORM HERE -- WE HAVE
HAD MANY DIFFICULTIES WITH
REMOTE INTERPRETING INCLUDING
EVERY CHOOSING OURSELVES ARE
GOING ON RECORD TO SAY THAT WE
CANNOT GUARANTEE THE ACCURACY
OF PART BECAUSE -- ATTORNEY
STARGAZER WITNESSES WHO PRE
-- YOU CAN'T HEAR THEM THE
VOICE IS CUT OFF THE PROPERTY
CALL THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
INCARCERATED HAVE TO BE BROUGHT
IN BECAUSE THERE IS NO WAY
THAT WE CAN DO SIMULTANEOUS
INTERPRETING IT'S JUST MANY
MANY PROBLEMS THANK YOU AGAIN
THERE IF YOU COULD RAPIDLY
SETTING BUT IT MUST BE WITH THE
RIGHT TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU FOR
LETTING THANK YOU FOR CALLING
MEXICO TO ALIGN EIGHTY TWO
PLACE LAST HELLO MY NAME IS
FEDERAL SIDE KNOWN -- MYSELF
ACCORDING TO OCCUR -- -- WOULD
LIKE TO THE TO THE SAME ISSUES
I'VE BEEN REPORTING FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WE HAVE BEEN HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH OUR MICROSOFT
TEAMS ON OTHER PLATFORMS I'M
NOT A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WE
SERVE AND I'M NOT TECHNICALLY
SAVVY SO FOR THEM TO DOWNLOAD
AN APP AND DATE AND CONNECTED
IT TO THE DIFFERENT STEPS JUST
TO GET CONNECTED TO A HEARING
MEXICO REALLY HARD FOR THEM
ALSO TO GET COMMITTEE FOR
THEM TO COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR
ATTORNEYS IS A REALLY HARD FOR
THEM TO DO IT WITH THE DECKER
AND THE TECHNOLOGY CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE -- OUR HOUSE HERE IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY -- THANKS
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING
MEXICO TO LINE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
UNITED CONTRACTORS I WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE PROVIDED BY MARC WATTS
REPRESENTING TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNORS MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS TO INVEST -- ONE
TIME REVENUES INTO MULTI
MODAL TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
INCLUDING PRIORITY RAIL AND
TRANSIT ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
AND GRADE SEPARATIONS AT THE
TRANSPORTATION CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY ALSO BELIEVED SO
THAT MORE CAN BE DONE WITH THE
STATE'S WINDFALL OF STATE AND
FEDERAL REVENUES TO SUPPORT OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
-- WHICH ARE PRIME CANDIDATES
FOR ONE TIME INVESTMENTS HELP
CREATE AND SUSTAIN LIVING
WAGE JOBS AND CREATE POSITIVE
RIPPLE EFFECTS THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE ECONOMY -- WE CAN ALSO
ACHIEVE -- GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS AND OTHER CLIMATE
CHANGE HEALTH AND EQUITY --
GOLDSTRIKE VESTMENT OF TARGETED
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXEO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS BY NAME IS AUGGIE
BELCHER AND WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS REGIONAL
COUNCIL FOR CALLING -- IN
CONJUNCTION WITH TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED
CONTRACTORS ON ISSUES TRUE
WE HAD MORE LIKE TO ECHO OUR
SUPPORT FOR TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO OUR STATE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON CRITICALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES LIKE
TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH THE
TESTIMONY FROM TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN LOCAL BRIDGE REPAIR AND
REPLACEMENT PROJECTS IN OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN LOCAL SAFETY
IMPROVEMENT THAT BENEFITS ALL
USERS THANK IN ADVANCE WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THANKS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THE SIGNIFICANT
ONE TIME INVESTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PRECHECK YOU CALLING
NEXT WE GO TO LINE NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
GUESTS COREY ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS
FOR STANISLAUS SANTA BARBARA
SAN LUIS OBISPO IN THE
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY FOR
CEMETERY -- IN MONTEREY BRIEFLY
ONE ECHO SUPPORT FOR ITEM
NUMBER ONE BY THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MR PIMENTEL ON TVA ON
ITEM NUMBER TWO ECHO SUPPORTS
A COMMENT MADE BY MR WATCH
AND MISS VALENTINE -- IF WE
WORKING CREEK AT T.
BY THE DISTRICT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION OVER WHAT THE GOVERNOR
HAD STATED WE WOULD FUND
PROJECT THAT AIMS TO DISCORD
AB OR OVER AND FACULTY FIVE
AND THEN ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE OTHER ONE COMPUTER PROGRAMS
WILL HELP SMALL COUNTY UP ON
MULTI MODAL PROJECTS IN LAST
WEEK ON ITEM TWENTY I WANT TO
SUPPORT THE EXTENSION OF THE
CAP ON THE INDIRECT COST RATE
PROPOSAL THANKS UP ACCOUNTS
FOR SPONSORING THAT ITEM AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND ALL
THREE ITEMS THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT WE GO TO LINE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD THIS IS
KATIE WATTERS SMITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION AND WE'RE CALLING ON
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR TO PROTECT AND
STRENGTHEN PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AND STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
AND THE GYM BUDGET BECAUSE
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE ACTION THE
PAY RATE FOR BOTH PROGRAMS WILL
GO DOWN AT THE END OF THIS YEAR
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE OF THAT
LOW WAGE WORKERS CAN AFFORD
TO USE THESE CRITICAL BENEFITS
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THANKS TO THE TO LINE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WOULD
BE SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF AT THE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIA BONTA BURKE
THE PRESEASON FOR THE DOCK
RECOMMENDATION ON ITEM FORTY
FOUR TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDING TO THE COURT
AS WELL AND ITEM FORTY SEVEN
REJECTING THE TRAILER BUILT
LANGUAGE TO MAKE PERMANENT
REMOTE PROCEEDINGS WHICH HAD
BEEN VERY PROBLEMATIC BOTH ARE
COURT REPORTERS AND COURT USERS
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS
IT STOD DISAPPOINTMENT THAT
OUR HUMBLE REQUEST FOR SEVEN
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
A TRANSCRIPT RATE INCREASE
FOR COURT REPORTERS WOULD
NOT INCLUDED NOR WOULD BE
A HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
WITH SEVENTY MILLION ON GOING
INCLUDED FOR EXPENDING PRE
TRIAL RELEASE WE HOPE THAT
THE -- LEGISLATOR CONTINUES
TO LOOK AT THESE ITEMS AS
THE -- BUDGET CONTINUES TO
MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING
NEXT WE GO TO LINE ONE
OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
I GOT TO GET OUT BUTTE -- HI MY
NAME IS ERIC SOTO -- THE STATE
PRESIDENT BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS I'M CALLING THE
BOYS -- OPPOSITION TO ISSUE
THIRTEEN TO THE MAY REVISE --
YOU BELIEVE IN MIND USUALLY
MEMBERS BELIEVE THAT IT IS
A GRAVE MISTAKE TO ELIMINATE
OVER TWO HUNDRED PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN POSITIONS IN
THE CORRECTIONS PSYCHIATRIC
INPATIENT PROGRAMS LIKE PETS
ARE TRAINED AND LICENSED TO
PROVIDE QUALITY MENTAL HEALTH
CARE -- TO THOSE SUFFERING
FROM MENTAL ILLNESS IN OUR
PRISONS WE HAVE WORKED ROB
CAN DEFINITELY AND RESTORE
LIVES AND THE LIVES OF OUR
HOUSE HOUSEHOLDS PROVIDING
THAT MENTAL HEALTH CARE FOR
THE STATE AGAIN I URGE --
HELLO VOTE ON DEC THIRTEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS FOR CALLING
NEXT WE GO TO LINE ONE OH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY
NAME IS AMY KOCH KO THIS IS
AN ISSUE NUMBER FORTY SEVEN
-- CIVIL CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS
I AM A COREY PORTER IN ORANGE
CALIFORNIA I DID APPRECIATE
THAT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
ON NUMBERS FORTY SEVEN Q.
REJECTED PROPOSAL AND --
WITHOUT THE COLDER INPUT
ON IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING
MEXICO TO LINE ONE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS WENT INTO BACK ALONG
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND THE BAY AREA
TOLL AUTHORITY ON INSTRUCTABLES
ITEM ONE RELATED TO THE TRAILER
BILL FOR THE TRANSPORTATION
DEVELOPMENT ACT AND ITEM TO
ALIGN MY COMMENT WITHOUT THE
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF INCREASED
INVESTMENT IN TRANSIT RAIL
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION GRADE
CROSSING THIS IS A GREAT
INVESTMENT OF THESE ONE
TIME MONEY ON AND THEN ONE
LAST COMMENT WITH REGARD TO
ITEM TWENTY WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND EXPANDING ENTREE
THE BILL TO CAP THE CAL TRANS
OVERHEAD RATE THAT WE WOULD
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER
EXPANDING THAT TO INCLUDE
PUBLIC TOLL AGENCIES LIKE THE
BAY AREA TOLL AUTHORITY --
WHICH ARE CURRENTLY PAYING
UPWARDS OF TWENTY SIX PERCENT
IN ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD
AND THOSE CRAVINGS WOULD GO
RIGHT BACK INTO ON ENSURING
THAT OUR STATE OWNED BRIDGES
THAT WE OPERATE OUR MEETING
TODAY CONDITION OF GOOD REPAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU
NEXT WE GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
READ AND SHARE MEMBERS ENTERING
INTO HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
TWO CLIENTS -- ONE THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND --
TO METROLINK -- RECORDS ACTION
OVER TO THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING PACKAGES
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
WHO WILL OF THAT PACKAGE
THE METROLINK ALSO EXPRESSLY
SUPPORTS OUR FUNDING THAT WE
MADE AVAILABLE MR.
GRAYSON PACKAGE OFFERS ZERO
MISSION RAIL AND TRANSIT
EQUIPMENT APPLICATIONS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE -- WE URGE
APPROVAL AND THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROJECTS FOR WHICH ONLY
MICROGRAM ACTUALLY PLANNING
PARTNER DURING THE RESOURCES
PROVIDED WITH MEASURE M.
AND THE OLYMPICS READY THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT RUSSIA HAS
IDENTIFIED AND A BUNCH OF
THESE GROUPS FOR PROGRAM AND
MEDICAL GROUPS TWENTY EIGHT
BY TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT --
LISTED PROJECTS SPECIFICALLY
THE FOUR PILLAR PROJECTS
WHICH ARE REAL IMPROVEMENTS
THAT WILL BE INTEGRAL TOWARDS
MOVING PEOPLE IN THE REGION
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND BEYOND
THANKS FOR THOSE REASONS -- WE
ARE COOL THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT WE GO TO LINE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JAMES FEDERAL ACTOR
AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL OF LABOUR'S I'M CALLING
TODAY TO ADDRESS AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER TWO THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE INFRASTRUCTURE
SPENDING BUT I COULD JUST ALIGN
MY COMMENTS -- WHAT DOES --
MARK WATCHING JOHN A VALENTINE
OF TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA
I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT YOU
KNOW THE STATE IS IN THE UNIQUE
POSITION TO USE THIS ONE CALLED
MONEY TO DOUBLE DOWN ON A
DEMONSTRATED SUCCESS S.
B.
ONE IS BROUGHT TO THE
STATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU CALLING
NEXT TO THE TREE LINE ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SHE'S MY
CAROL WITH THE WEAPONS FEDERAL
LAW POVERTY -- WE'RE CALLING
TODAY ON TWO ISSUES ONE IS WE
HAVE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AROUND
THE CAL CLEAN PROPOSAL AND
THE OTHER PROPOSALS RELATING
TO ENCAMPMENTS -- WE HAVE NOT
YET SEEN BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE -- CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT THE HOME WITH INDIVIDUAL
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE GIVEN
BOTH ADEQUATE NOTICE SO THEY
CAN MOVE THAT THEY NEED TO AND
THAT THE STATE INDEED IS GOING
TO CLEAN UP AND KAMAN THAT
THOSE BOOK PERSONAL BELONGINGS
BE STORED SO WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT I DIDN'T A LOT OF TWELVE
AND SIXTEEN AND THEN LASTLY
I JUST WANT TO -- -- SUPPORT
THE COMMENTS -- NEARBY -- AT
THE ARE YOU ABOUT NOT SEEN
ANYTHING IN HERE TO DEAL WITH
COURT REPORTERS THE TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT FUNDS FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR LEGAL
SERVICES YOU MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN DEAL WITH THE MANY PROBLEMS
THAT WON'T COME CALIFORNIA
TEAMS CONTINUE TO SUFFER FROM
SO WITH THOSE COMMENTS WE ARE
WE ARE FINISHED THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR CALLING PRE SHADED
NEXT WE GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS BILL HIGGINS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS
AND WE REPRESENT -- THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
ORGANIZATIONS MANY OF THE
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AGENCY THAT LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
STATE IN SOME OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE OPERATORS SO WE SUPPORT
-- THE BUDGET ITEM NUMBER
ONE PROVIDED NEEDED SUPPORT
TO TRANSPORTATION SEASON AND
ALMOST ALL OF OUR AGENCIES
ARE INVOLVED IN PROGRAMMING
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS AND
THERE IS MORE THAN ENOUGH SPEED
THERE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT
AND -- ACKNOWLEDGE AND SUPPORT
PROPOSALS THAT MIGHT EVEN ASK
FOR LIKE FREE SOLUTION FOR
CONGESTED CORRIDORS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT CAN PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL HELP TOWARD THE
STATE CLIMATE AND MOBILITY GOAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THANKS TO GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES GOOD AFTERNOON NOT SURE
HER NAME IS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
INTERPRETERS THE CALIFORNIA
RECORDERS ASSOCIATION AND
UNITED PUBLIC EMPLOYEE ON
ITEM FORTY SEVEN WE APPRECIATE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO
REJECT THE PROPOSED BUDGET
TRAILER BILL RELATED TO CIVIL
COURT PROCEEDINGS -- AND WE
ASK THE COMMITTEE TO REJECT
THIS PROPOSAL IT'S TOO MUCH
TOO SOON AND TOO MANY PROBLEMS
-- AND OF COURSE RIGHT NOW
WOODS TO EVALUATE WHAT'S
BEEN GOING ON BEFORE WE GET
MEXICO TO LINE UP ONE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M
GONNA LET NOTHING WORKS MORE
ON THE HALF OF SAN BENITO
COUNTY WANTED TO ALIGN MY
OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY
JANA VALENTINE AND THE COURT
IN A REVISED PROPOSAL AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR OTHER TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM THANK YOU
AND ACTUALLY GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI THIS AND KEEP DONE ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SO CALLED COUNTY COALITION
IN BORDEAUX THE ICE EUROPEAN
RED CROSS REPLOGLE LIMITING
THE AMOUNT THAT THE STATE
CAN CHARGE SELF COUNTY PARKER
WITH THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THE ONE THAT MUCH
THANK YOU FOR CALLING
AT THE TIME NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THIS MODERATOR ARE APPRECIATED
IF YOU COULD -- TRY ONE
MORE TIME TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE THAT WISHES TO
SPEAK IF YOU LIKE TO MAKE
A COMMENT IN THE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE A FEW
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TO ME R.
I'M JUST -- URGING EVERYONE --
CONSIDERING THE REMOTE -- AXES
-- FOR TRIALS IN THE COURTS
AND ACCEPT YOUR OB IMAGINE
YOURSELF IN A FOREIGN COUNTRY
IMAGINE YOURSELF CONVOCATION
DISCONNECTED FROM FAMILY AND
FRIENDS CONNECTED ON THEIR
OWN AND THE KEY AND TRYING TO
NAVIGATE A JUDICIAL SYSTEM THAT
IT'S WHAT'S BORING TO YOU AT
THE PLACE THAT YOU'RE VISITING
PLEASE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
PEOPLE WHO USE THE SERVICES
OF INTERPRETERS ATTORNEYS
AND BAIT BASIC EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM AND THE ACCESS THAT
THEY NEED THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING PROPER INTERPRETATION
AND NOT YES PLEASE TALK TO
THE PROFESSIONALS TALK TO THE
PEOPLE WITH THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND WHO DO THIS WORK DAY
AFTER DAY I'M NOT WHAT IS IT
THAT THEY NEED RATHER THAN
TRYING TO IMPOSE A SYSTEM
ULTIMATE MONNING TEMPERATURE
THAT DOES NOT SPEAK EVERYONE
AND THAT IT'S GREAT FOR UP
AND THEN MAKE AS AN EMERGENCY
MEASURE BUT NOT AS A REGULAR
STANDARD WHAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
MY NAME IS VERONICA BONTA
FELINE AND OF COURSE CERTIFIED
INTERPRETER WORKING FOR THE
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA I'M CALLING
IN FAVOR OF REJECTING THE
TRAIL DOWN I AM VERY GRATEFUL
TO HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK SAFELY COME HOME GET INTO
CRISIS I THINK MOST UNDER WHICH
WE ARE OPERATING IN BARELY
ADEQUATE FOR THIS EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES NOT TO BE ADOPTED
AS A STANDARD PRACTICE LANGUAGE
ACTIVIST DECLARED COMPROMISED
MICHAEL TECHNOLOGY NOT ONLY
ON THE COURT SIDE BUT ALSO ON
THE CORE USER AND EXPRESSLY
FOR DOES IT MEAN WHEN WE DO
COMPANION INTERPRETATION PEOPLE
THE COMPANY CHAU THEIR COURT
OFFICERS CANNOT HEAR WHEN THEY
ALLEN PEOPLE TALKING ON THE
PITCH TRYING TO THE INTERPRETER
WELL WE DO CONSECUTIVE
INTERPRETATION MANY JUDGES
THE STRUGGLE -- WE HAD BEEN
WORKING WITH INTERPRETER AND
THE REQUIRED EXTRA TIME PEOPLE
STRAIGHT DON'T TAKE TIME OFF TO
ATTEND HEARINGS THAT THEY DON'T
KNOW WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO BE
CALLED BETWEEN EIGHT THIRTY
AND TWELVE AND MANY TIMES AFTER
WAITING ALL MORNING THANK YOU
NEED TO BE CONTINUE BECAUSE THE
COURT HAS RUN OUT OF TIME IF
YOU TRULY CARE ABOUT LANGUAGE
ACTIVE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AREA
THANK YOU VERY DISCUSSION AT
THIS TIME AND HE WILL REJECT
THE TRAIL BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THANKS TO GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD ABOUT
THE AMENDMENTS WILL OF LITTLE
SPANISH INTERPRETER -- I'M ALSO
GOING TO SUPPORT TO REJECT THAT
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN I WHICH IS
THE REMOTE INTERPRETING BILL
-- WHAT COMES TO MY MIND IS
TWO REASONS I BELIEVE -- A
LOT OF THESE CASES WILL COME
BACK ON APPEAL FOR -- ARE
INSUFFICIENT OR INADEQUATE
LANGUAGE ACCESS -- AND THAT'S
GOING TO A COMPROMISE GOING
TO IMPOSE ADDITIONAL COSTS ON
THE COURTS ALSO -- I BELIEVE
DOING NAY -- BUT MOST HEARING
IN THE COMPETITIVE MODE IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN INTERPRETER
-- CHARGING -- HALF DAY RATE
TOOL FOR DATE RAPE SO AN
INTERPRETER WILL MOST LIKELY
-- A JUDGE WILL SLOW THE RATE
AS OPPOSED TO A HALF THE RATE
WHEN DOING THE -- CONSECUTIVE
MAULED BY -- MOKE HEARING AND
THAT'S GONNA IMPOSE ADDITIONAL
COSTS ON THE COURT AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WE GO TO LINE SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YES
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M ALSO CALLING TO VOICE MY
APPRECIATION TO ISSUE NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN THE REMOTE --
HEARINGS -- I HAVE BEEN VERY
LUCKY TO BE -- INTERPRETING
THE MONTHLY -- DURING THIS TIME
BUT I CAN -- -- PERSONALLY TELL
YOU CAN TELL YOUR FIRSTHAND
OF ALL THE DIFFICULTIES THAT
REMOTE INTERPRETATION HAS BEEN
I URGE A NO VOTE L.
NUMBER THIRTY I'M SORRY
CHIU FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU
CHECK YOUR CALLING THANK YOU
NEXT IN HEADLINE ONE HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ALEX ALTER I AM ALSO
A SPANISH INTERPRETER AND I
HAVE -- THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO REMOTE INTERPRETER EACH
FROM HOME AND I CAN TELL
YOU WITHOUT IT'S BEEN VERY
FRUSTRATING AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S HELP EITHER SIDE AND IT
HAS MANY OF THE DIFFICULTIES
LIKE MY OTHER COLLEAGUES HAVE
MENTIONED SO IT NEEDS TO BE
UPGRADED TO PROPER TECHNOLOGY
WERE SIMULTANEOUS INTERPRETER
CAN BE USED FOR THAT -- THE
INTERPRETER CAN SPEAK CLEARLY
AND SPEED UP THE HEARING THAT'S
ONE OF THE FRUSTRATIONS BUT
AT THIS MOMENT THE WAY THINGS
ARE I AM CURRENTLY FOR A NO
VOTE ON ITEM FORTY SEVEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR LISTENING
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
NEXT LOOK ONLINE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD
HELLO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY AND I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE PROTECT YOUR
RECORD PROJECT AND I M.
COURT REPORTER CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED ONE ONE THREE SEVEN
ZERO I AM URGING YOU TO FOLLOW
THE RECOMMENDATION AND REJECT
ON ISSUE NUMBER FORTY SEVEN
REMOTE REPEATING AND WE AND IN
ALIGNMENT WITH OUR INTERPRETER
COLLEAGUES AS WELL AS COURT
REPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
YOU KNOW THAT THAT MEANS MORE
WORK AND YOU NEED TO BE LOOKED
AT THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
MEXICO CAROLINA ONE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
RIGHT HI MY NAME IS CHRISTY
KARRAS NINE WICKETS BOTHER YOU
LACK FORMALLY THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION AGAINST SEXUAL
ASSAULT I APPRECIATE THE MAY
REVISIONS INCLUSION OF ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN BACK
OF THE VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT
FUNDING AND URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO INCREASE THE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE MORE STABILITY FOR THE
VICTIM SERVICES RSU COMMITTEE
TO INCLUDE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR
SEXUAL AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PREVENTION DRUG THE PROVIDING
ONGOING PREVENTION FUNDING
IS CRUCIAL FOR ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE STOP
VIOLENCE BEFORE IT OCCURS AND
BUILD HEALTHY COMMUNITIES --
WE'RE HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS
THINGS THAT AREN'T AND AREN'T
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
CAN QUEUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR AGAIN WOULD YOU
PLEASE CHECK ONE MORE TIME
IF YOU LIKE TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME WE
DO HAVE ONE IN Q.
ONE MOMENT
YOU GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
THE NUTCRACKER WITH CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THEIR
REMOTE TRAINER BILL LANGUAGE
ON BEHALF OF THE PLAINTIFFS
BAR WE DRUNK REPEAL THAT THE
COURTS NEED THE TOOLS NECESSARY
TO WORK THEIR WAY OUT OF THE
NOT THE BACKLOG ENDEMIC IN
WITHOUT AUTHORIZATION FOR
AMERICAN HEARING THE ENORMOUS
BACKLOG WILL LAST FOR YEARS
AND YEARS AND YEARS AND WE
MUST EQUIPMENT OR THE TOOLS
THAT THEY NEED TO CARVE THEIR
WAY OUT OF BEING CLOSED THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
MEXICO TO LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
HE'S GLAD GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR NUMBERS IF YOU DO IF YOU
HAVE A PUBLIC ADVOCATE I ASK
MY COLLEAGUES AT THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY S.
C.
R.
U.
AND LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION
IN ASKING YOU TO ADD SIXTY
MILLION ON GOING TO THE
EQUAL ACCESS FUND TO BACKFILL
THE DECREASE IN LEGAL AID
FUNDING IN CALIFORNIA M.
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF AN
EXPANDING COMMUNITY OF LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS IMPACTED
BY JOB LOSS AND FINANCIAL
SECURITY WE ALSO URGE YOU
TO INCREASE THE USE OF
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN FUNDING
FOR HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
SERVICES FROM SIXTY TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE TO
MEXICO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR --
MY NAME IS CONCEPCION MENDED
SPANISH LANGUAGE INTERPRETER
WITH THE LOS ANGELES AIRPORT
AND I HAD BEEN AN ONSITE
INTERPRETER -- FACING THE
CHALLENGES POSED BY THE
-- WEBEX -- SEATING IN THE
COURTROOM AND CAN TELL YOU
FIRST HAND THAT THE QUALITY
OF SERVICES RENDERED TO OUR
CLIENT IS -- MINIMAL AT BEST
THE CLIENT WILL LEAVE THE
COURTROOM COMPLETELY LOST
AND CLUELESS WITH THE NOISE
TECHNICAL I FEEL THERE IS
DIFFICULTY SOMETIMES WIFI DOWN
SO TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION
ALL OF THESE CHALLENGES I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A
NO VOTE ON FORTY SEVEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHELLE EVEN CERTIFIED
SPANISH INTERPRETER WITH LOS
ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY OPPOSITION
TO ISSUE FORTY SEVEN WE MUST
NEVER FORGET THE PARTIES RIGHT
TO DUE PROCESS AND WITH THE
CURRENT STATE OF AFFAIRS THE
WAY REMOTE INTERPRETATION IS
OPERATING AT PRESENT WE CANNOT
GUARANTEE THE PARTIES THERE
DUE PROCESS IT IS THAT YOU KNOW
IN ADEQUATE AT THE TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR
CALLING GRAND PRIX SHOULD IT
MEXICO TO LINE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
I'M AN EMPLOYEE AND SANTA
CLARA COUNTY I WE HAVE BEEN
INTERPRETING REMOTELY AND COURT
I THOUGHT THIS LAST YEAR I CAN
TELL YOU FOR EXAMPLE THAN ONE
ARRANGEMENT THAT SHOULD TAKE
FIFTEEN MINUTES TAKES ABOUT
FORTY MINUTES BECAUSE AT THE
INADEQUATE TECHNOLOGY THAT
WE HAVE IT'S ALSO INTERESTING
THAT WHILE WE ARE NEGOTIATING
A NEW CONTRACT ITS TRAILER
BILL IS PRESENTED TO THE
COMMITTEE AND END REMOTE
INTERPRETING IS THAT ONE OF
THE NEGOTIATE A BOWL ITEM
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN
THANKS FOR THE TO LINE UP ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
MATT ROBINSON ON BEHALF WOOD
COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT AS
WELL AS CALTRAIN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
PACKAGE FOR TRANSPORTATION
OBVIOUSLY WE ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO SEE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS
BUT WE THINK IT'S AN ACTUAL
STARTING PLACE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TO CONSIDER THE ISSUE
THANK YOU FOR CALLING THEM
THE NEXT WE GO TO LINE ONE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ON THE SOTO
I'M A PROGRAM MANAGER AND E.
I APPRECIATE THE MAY REVISION
INCLUSIONS THAT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IMPACT FELT
FOR THE VICTIMS OF CRIME
ACT FINDING AN URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO INCREASE THAT
TO THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS I ALSO URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR SEXUAL AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PREVENTION WORK IS THE KEY
TO SHIFTING CULTURES AND
ADDRESSING ROOT CAUSES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES OUR PREVENTION
PROGRAMMING DEPENDS ON ON
ARTS I'M I'M GOING FUNDING TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE OUR WORK
AND SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY IN
ORDER TO HELP PREVENT AGAINST
SEXUAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
BUILD HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
FOR HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS AND
CONSENT ARE THE MORE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO CALL
THE MEXICO LINE OF ONE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JANET
KICK ON I AM AN INTERPRETER
WORKING FOR THE STATE COURT
I AM CALLING IN OPPOSITION
-- AND URGED TO REJECT ITEM
FORTY SEVEN OUTLOOK IT'S NOT
WORKING THEY ARE THE WHOLE
REVOKED INSURANCE IS IN
ANOTHER ROOM IT'S A MECHANISM
TO TRY PEOPLE THERE'S JUST A
TWO BIT OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
FOR INDIGENT PEOPLE AND IT'S
JUST NOT PROVIDING SERVICES
SPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
MOST VULNERABLE WHO CAN'T
SPEAK ENGLISH WELL ENOUGH
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN
THANKS WE GET TO LINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL
FERREIRA AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
INTERPRETERS LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND I'VE BEEN WORKING
AS AN INTERPRETER FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I AM ALSO CALLING
IN TO SUPPORT FOLLOWING THE
RECOMMENDATION TO REJECT THIS
CONCEPT AROUND INTERPRETING
INTERPRETING IT IS REALLY NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR THE BASQUE
MAJORITY OF THINGS THAT HAPPEN
IN THE QUARTER OF OUR SPIRITS
DURING COLD IT HAS BEEN REALLY
QUITE A NIGHTMARE AND THIS IS
BRINGING A LOT OF LIABILITIES
DOWN ON TO THE COURT IN SOME
PARTS OF THE APPEAL IT IS ALSO
-- PUTTING A LOT MORE BARRIERS
WITH THE DIGITAL DIVIDE MANY
OF OUR PEOPLE DO NOT KNOW HOW
TO MAKE IT BE IMMIGRANT PEOPLE
DID NOT VOTE OR HELP ACCESS
TO THAT SORT OF THING THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO DO THIS WE'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC RIGHT
NOW IN THE EXAMPLE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING DURING THE PANDEMIC
INCIDENTS -- THE WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO WITH THE ARE IN THE
FUTURE THIS IS GOING TO BE A
BIG PROBLEM BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
YET SELL ANY OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT ARE SHOWING UP AND WE
THOUGHT IT'S A RESPONSIBLE TO
GO FORWARD WITH THIS AT THIS
POINT WITHOUT FULLY HAVING FULL
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT IT IS THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND THAT'S
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
APPRECIATED MODERATOR COULD
YOU TELL US HOW MANY REMAINING
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE HAVE
THERE ARE TWO MORE IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU GO AHEAD
WELCOME MEXICO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
SAMANTHA LOU BRANI AND I AM A
SPANISH INTERPRETER CERTIFIED
IN LOS ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT
I AM ALSO CALLING IN OPPOSITION
TO ITEM FORTY SEVEN I HAVE BEEN
WORKING IN THE COURT ROOM WHILE
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
BEEN DOING REMOTE INTERPRETING
AND I'M SEEING IT FROM THIS
POINT OF VIEW AND IT IS NOT
WORKING MOST OF THE JUDGES
DO NOT WANT TO USE REMOTE
INTERPRETING BECAUSE AS PEOPLE
HAVE SAID IT TAKE MUCH MUCH
LONGER AND SO PEOPLE OFTEN
TIMES JUST AREN'T EVEN COMING
BEFORE THE JETS THERE YET THE
ATTORNEY APPEARS FOR THEM OTHER
PEOPLE ARE HAVING TO LISTEN
TO INTERPRETATION ON THEIR
PRIVATE CELL PHONE AND A LOT
OF OUR NOT LANGUAGE PROFICIENT
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE UNLIMITED
MINUTES ON THEIR PHONES SO
THEY ARE BASICALLY BEING OUT
TO PAY FOR AN INTERPRETER
-- I JUST WOULD AND I WOULD
ALSO ECHO EVERYTHING THAT HAS
BEEN SAID BY MY COLLEAGUES MY
INTERPRETERS AS WELL AS COURT
REPORTERS I DO NOT BELIEVE
IT WILL CARRY OUT JUSTICE
IN OUR COURT SYSTEM THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TWO LINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
GLORIA LANCASTER I'M CALLING
THE POLICE ASKED THE BOARD TO
STRONGLY REJECT ITEM NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN BECAUSE WE'RE
FORGETTING ABOUT THAT PEOPLE
WERE SERVICE CENTER AND WE'RE
NOT DOING EQUAL ACCESS TO
JUSTICE TO THE FAIR TIMELY
AND EFFICIENT RESOLUTION OF
THEIR CASES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR CALLING MEXICO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES I THANK YOU AGAIN CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CALLING AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE WORLD INTERPRETERS IN
CALIFORNIA I THANK YOU FOR
COMING UP ABOUT TO KNOW THAT
WE CARE ABOUT THE WORK WE DO
AND I THINK YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW
IMPORTANT WORK IS THE REASON
I'M SPEAKING AGAIN IT'S BECAUSE
YOU'VE HEARD FROM EMPLOYEES
IN URBAN AREAS I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT BURL CONTRACTORS
CANNOT CHARGE FLAT RATE AND THE
PROPOSED USE OF APPLE CHANGES
FORCED US TO CHARGE A LOT MORE
THAN WE NEED YOU FOR TRAVEL
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO WORK
FOR REAL COUNTY ONCE AGAIN --
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT FLAT
RATE BUT POSSIBLE AND THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ALLOWS COURTS
TO USE THE SURPLUS CONTRACTORS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE COMMENTS BUT
BEFORE I OPENED IT UP TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE I
JUST WANT TO TELL THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT THERE ARE
NONE OF SEVERAL ISSUES AND THE
US SPECIAL PANELS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED AND -- ARE A BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE FIVE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS I ALSO WANT TO REMIND
THE PUBLIC THAT -- THIS IS THE
LAST MEETING OF SUB COMMITTEE
SUB BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FIVE
BUT ON TUESDAY JUNE FIRST WILL
BE THE FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE
VOTE ON ON THESE ISSUES AS
WELL SO I WANT TO MOVE ON
AND ASK OF MY COLLEAGUES
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
-- IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
SENATE CORTESE THANK YOU
MINIATURE -- LET ME --
REFERENCE THERE'S A COUPLE
THINGS TO A DELIGHTED TO
MAKE SURE ON THE RECORD --
ONE OF THEM DIED WE HEARD
SOME TESTIMONY ON FROM THE
PUBLIC JUST NOW -- PARTY
ISSUE THIRTEEN -- ACCORDING
TO ACCORDING TO MY PACKET
MY AGENDA TODAY -- WE WILL
BE ABLE WITH AN AYE VOTE
ON ON THE RECOMMENDATION WE
WOULD BE REJECTING -- THE
PROPOSALS -- IN A -- A SUPPORT
THAT REJECTION AND FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING IS -- -- THAT
CIVIC LEASING TERMS OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY THAT'S WHAT WHAT WAS
-- A SUGGESTED OR RECOMMENDED
SO -- IF I'M INCORRECT ABOUT
THAT -- I WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO
BE CORRECTED NOW BEFORE CASTLE
VOTE OTHERWISE MY UNDERSTAND
IS SAID -- WE'RE PROCEEDING
WITH REJECTING -- THAT PROPOSAL
UNDER PARTY ISSUE THIRTEEN
THAT'S RIGHT SENATE QUARTERS
HE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND --
ON A SEPARATE ISSUE THAT
I ACTUALLY KNOW ME JUST BE
MAILED A GOT A CURSE ME MAY
HAVE JUST BEEN AN OMISSION ON
-- -- YOU OR JUST NOT LABELED
IN A WAY THAT I COULD PICK UP
ON IT -- EITHER UNDER THE --
YES PART OF OUR PROCEEDINGS
-- UP TO THIS POINT TWO OR
OR OR ELSEWHERE IN THE MAY
REVISE SORE YOU KNOW ELSEWHERE
IN -- IN ANOTHER SUBCOMMITTEE
OR BUDGET COMMITTEE BUT THAT
WOULD BE ON THE ISSUE OF -- THE
FIRE UNDER FIRE RESPONSE CLICK
SAFETY -- THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
INVESTMENT BY THE STATE WHICH
HAS BEEN WELL RECEIVED WELL
UTILIZED IN SO CALLED MOSES
SYSTEMS -- I I JUST WANTED TO
INDICATE ON THE RECORD THAT
-- IN ORDER TO CLARIFY -- MY
CONCERN AND IN RECOMMENDATION
THAT THERE WOULD BE -- IS
SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
OF A TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS -- APPROPRIATION THE
TO COVER ADDITIONAL GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS AND OF COURSE BEYOND
THE GEOGRAPHIC AREAS AS WE
ALL KNOW TO SUPPORT MUTUAL
AID -- IN THAT REGARD -- THAT
A LETTER WOULD BE FORTHCOMING
AND I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT
ON THE RECORD TODAY SO THAT
I AM IN INTEGRITY SUPPORTING
SUPPORTING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
TODAY WITHOUT -- YOU KNOW
WITHOUT ANYTHING IN WRITING
ON THAT PARTICULAR TOPIC TODAY
-- AND THEN THAT WAS ISSUED TO
GO AHEAD SENATOR SORRY HERE
AND THEN -- I BELIEVE -- BASED
ON A PER CONVERSATION THAT
-- -- MY COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES
SENATOR NEWMAN WILL BE SPEAKING
-- ON THE ISSUE OF TRAVIS
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE HEARD A QUITE A BIT
ABOUT -- JUST NOW ON THE
MODERATED COMMENTS ON ON THE
PUBLIC LINES SENATE QUARTERS
IT I'M SORRY EXCUSE ME DID YOU
WANT -- YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OR LA -- TO RESPOND
TO THE ISSUE YOU JUST BROUGHT
UP BEFORE YOU GO TO THE THE
NEXT ONE I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT
OR TAKE IT ALL AT THE END BUT
IF -- CONSULTANT RECOMMENDS
WE TAKE THEM ONE AT A TIME
THAT'S FINE AND YES WE CAN WHAT
DO WE DO THAT THEN THAT WAY
IF WE ARE IN DIFFERENT TOPIC
AREAS I FELT IT IS THERE ANY
COMMENT OR BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCER LA YO BUT IS IT
ISSUE THIRTEEN VACANCY WITH
THE FIRST ISSUE WAS -- PARTY
ISSUE THIRTEEN AND I WAS JUST
TRYING TO CONFIRM THAT -- THAT
WERE REJECTED YEAH THAT ARE
RECOMMENDATION WOULD REVERSE
THE MAY REVISE RECOMMENDATION
ESSENTIALLY YEAH OKAY I THINK
I THINK WE SAID YES RIGHT
YES OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S
ALL I NEEDED OKAY FOR THE
RECORD AND THE SECOND ISSUE
I THOUGHT THERE WAS A SECOND
ISSUE HAD TO DO WITH -- OF
A FIRE RESPONSE HE QUICKMAP
REALLY FIRE IT CAPITAL COULD
BE THE BEST MAN IN IN -- FIRE
THERE'D BEEN -- -- EITHER
EITHER GRANTS OR DIRECT FUNDING
FOR SO CALLED MOSES SYSTEMS
-- IN PAST BUDGET CYCLES I
DO NOT SEE THEM SHOWING UP
HERE I'M SORRY NOT TO BROUGHT
THAT UP EARLIER WHEN WE WERE
HAVING A DISCUSSION ON THE --
YES PORTION OF THE BUDGET BUT
MAYBE BETTER LATE THAN NEVER
I JUST WANT TO BRING IT UP NOW
IN BEING GIVEN THAT TODAY'S
-- YOU KNOW OF A VOTE ONLY AND
WE HAVE -- I I DO SUPPORT THE
BILL YES BUDGET THAT IS HERE
BUT I WANTED TO -- -- TO STATE
ON THE RECORD -- THAT THERE
WILL BE -- A COLLEAGUES MEMO
A BUDGET REQUEST MINIMAL --
SIGNED BY COLLEAGUES ARE COMING
FORWARD TO ASK OF FOR WHAT
I EXPECT WILL BE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO AUGMENT --
-- THE EXPANSION OF OF THOSE
MOSES SYSTEMS -- IN PLACES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE THAT CAPACITY
IF THERE'S ANY RESPONSE ON
THAT AGAIN PERHAPS IT'S IT'S
JUST NOT LABELED CLEARLY OR --
OR WORSE YET THAT IS LABELED
VERY CLEARLY AND I DIDN'T
READ IT I'M I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO BE CORRECTED IF IT'S
THERE SOMEWHERE BUT THEN I'D
LIKE TO HEAR THE SPECIFICS
IF NOT -- LIKE I SAID I JUST
WANT ON THE RECORD AWFUL UP
WITH A LETTER OKAY WELL WE'LL
OF COURSE YOU'RE RAISING IT
SO WE'LL ADDRESS IT I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S ANY CURRENT
OUR RESPONSE TO THAT BY DAHLE
OR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SENATOR ANDREW DUFFY
DEPARTMENT FINANCE --
NO YES IS BASED FIND THERE'S
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR POSITIONING -- IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'RE SPEAKING -- MORE
TOWARDS COMMUNICATION --
EQUIPMENT WITH MOSES SYSTEMS
-- I DON'T HAVE MUCH SEATS
ON THAT AT THE MOMENT I LOOK
FORWARD TO RECEIVING -- THE THE
LETTER -- THAT THAT'S ARE YOU
INDICATE -- WILL BE PROVIDED
AND AND TAKE A LOOK AT A
FURTHER LOOK THANK YOU MR DUFFY
THAT'S HOPEFUL -- AND THEN
LASTLY -- BUT I I DO I WILL
SAY THAT THE DELEO OF SEIZING
SO TOWARD THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- WE'RE UP
AT THIS POINT -- I DON'T HAVE
ANY INFORMATION ABOUT THE MOSES
SYSTEM BEING PROPOSED AS PART
OF THE -- YESS BUDGET BUT WE'D
BE HAPPY TO TAKE A LOOK AT --
SENATOR CORTESE'S LETTER OKAY
THANK YOU GO AHEAD IN ATTENDING
TO MANAGER IN BEFORE WE TOOK
THE RESPONSE ON -- BUT LET
ME LET ME PAUSE LET ME JUST
ALSO STATE OF FOR THE RECORD
IF IF FIRST OF ALL WE CAN GET
THIS QUESTION ANSWERED -- IN
A SORRY MADAM SHERRY DID NOT
-- OVER IT TO THIS EARLIER BUT
IT'S A QUESTION THAT'S BEEN
-- CIRCULATING AROUND FOR A
WHILE AND THAT IS -- IN -- THE
STAFF OF A RECOMMENDATION -- IN
ISSUE NINE PART B.
OF THE AGENDA AT THE TALKS
ABOUT -- IS FUNDING A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND WHICH WOULD COVER
THE LOCAL SHARE FOR FEDERAL
HAZARD MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAMS FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES -- IN IN OUR
REGION TECHNICAL ASSISTANT
CALLS FOR -- YES SO AGAIN I'M
STILL ON THE TOPIC WILL YES TO
IDENTIFY AND PROVIDE SUPPORT
INCLUDING APPLICATION SUPPORT
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND MY QUESTION IS -- WHAT THE
FIRM VERSION IF YOU WILL OF
A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WILL BE APPLIED AS WE KNOW
THERE'S DIFFERENT STANDARDS
COMMUNITIES OF CONCERN -- WHICH
IS A FEDERAL STANDARD -- IN
VIRUS SCREENING OTHERS AND I'M
JUST I I KNOW THAT I'M PART OF
A LETTER -- THAT HAS ALREADY
CIRCULATED -- ROPE RELATIVE TO
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET -- REQUESTS
SEEMED -- PERFECT CATION BUT
A POLIO OR A FINANCE HAS AN
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE TO THAT
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL MANAGER
BUT MR DUFFY DO YOU WANNA
START SURE AGAIN INTRODUCTION
APARTMENTS FINANCE -- SO SO
WITH WITHIN -- -- -- NOTED
MINISTRATIONS -- REQUESTS JUST
WANTED FIFTY MILLION -- THE THE
THE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
AS ONE HUNDRED MILLION TO TO
COVER -- -- THE LOCAL SHARE
OF THE HAZARD MITIGATION --
ASSISTANCE FRANCE AND ALSO TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE --
CENTER AS I THINK YOU KNOW NOT
ALL HE'S OR CITIES OR COUNTIES
ARE SIMILARLY SITUATED WITH
THE -- ABILITY TO -- TO APPLY
FOR GRANTS AND SO -- IT'S A
VISION THAT THESE RESOURCES
WILL PROVIDE FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE -- TO TO REALLY GET
THE CITIES AND COUNTIES -- WHO
MAY NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES OR
EXPERTISE -- TO SUCCEED AND
AND AND AND THE GROUNDS -- --
CITIZENS TO GET THEM OVER THE
FINISH LINE -- I'M DEFINITELY
LOOKING FORWARD TO RECEIVING
THE LETTER AND AND WE CAN
DISCUSS FURTHER ON ON THE
DEFINITIONS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES -- AND AS YOU NOTED
JURORS ARE MORE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THIS
WAS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT WE RAISED ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL AND NAME WAS X.
PRECISELY HOW DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE DEFINED
-- AND RESPONSES WE RECEIVED
FROM -- YES THEY INDICATED THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO OVERLAY THE
STATE'S HAZARD MAPS WITH ANY --
SOCIAL VULNERABILITY MAP -- OF
THE STATE HOWEVER WE DON'T HAVE
MUCH DETAILS BEYOND THAT -- AND
-- WOULD END IN COURAGE -- YES
TO PROVIDE GREATER DETAIL SOME
OF THE LEGISLATURE CAN HAVE A
MORE CLEAR SENSE OF PRECISELY
-- WHAT HOW DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE DEFINED
FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE GRANT
THANK OR DOES HE WE WILL OF
COURSE BUDGET STAFF WILL FOLLOW
UP ALSO WITH YOU TO GET FURTHER
INFORMATION AND -- WHATEVER
OTHER ISSUE YOU WANT TO RAISE
WITH THEM YEAH THAT'S -- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM SURE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET ON THE RECORD I THINK
ELIO FOR THE REMINDER -- --
OF WHAT WAS SAID EARLIER SO
-- LASTLY AND -- AGAIN THIS
IS WHERE I WAS PRECEDING MY
COMMENTARY BY SAYING THAT I
KNOW -- MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
NEWMAN -- IT HAS SOME COMMON
SEARCH RESET RESET SO EARLIER
I EXPECT HE WILL BE SPEAKING
ON -- THE -- TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE COMMENTS THAT
WE HEARD EARLIER IN TERMS OF
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION -- HE
HE AND I ARE OF OF LIKE MIND
-- IN TERMS OF THE REQUEST THE
CRITICALLY THE REQUEST THAT WAS
-- -- BROUGH FORD NOT ONLY IN
WRITING BIRTHDAY OR LEAVE BY
THE TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA
SO I'M GOING TO PAUSE THERE
BUT JUST IN CASE I DON'T HAVE
TO COME BACK AND COME IN AGAIN
MADAM CHAIR THAT A -- THAT ALL
DEFERRED TO CENTER NEWMAN ON
ON THIS TOPIC AND -- THAT I
WOULD JUST IN ADVANCE ASSOCIATE
MY COMMENTS WITH HIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SEND A COURTESY THERE
NEWMAN YES THANK YOU MANAGER
BUT LET ME LET ME START BY
BUILDING ON STELLAR CRETACEOUS
COMMENTS ABOUT -- PARTITION
NUMBER TWO -- -- AROUND THE
STATE BUDGET FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE -- SO APPRECIATE
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS I I ALSO
KNOW I SPEAK FOR OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE -- SUPPORT MANY
THE MAY REVISION TRANSPORTATION
PROPOSALS OFFERED BY THE
GOVERNOR -- THAT ARE PRESENT
HERE TODAY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
WE WE BELIEVE THE STATE'S
IN A UNIQUE POSITION TO MAKE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL ACCELERATE OUR PROGRESS
TOWARD MEETING SAFETY MOBILITY
CLIMATE HOUSING AND EQUITY
GOALS AT THE RECENT ON PRESENT
WINDFALL A STATE AND FEDERALLY
RESOURCES THAT UNDERPIN MUCH OF
THE MAY REVISED IN OUR OPINION
REPRESENTS A MAJOR OPPORTUNITY
FOR STRATEGIC -- IN FACT A
ONCE IN A LIFETIME INVESTMENT
INTO MULTIMODAL TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS THEY WILL HAVE A WIDE
RANGE OF MOBILITY AND CLIMATE
FRIENDLY IMPACTS OF SENATOR
QUOTATION I BOAL JOINED WITH
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
CHAIR SENATOR GONZALEZ WAS
SENATOR WIENER AND OTHERS
SEEKING ADDITIONAL BUDGET
INVESTMENTS DEVELOPED WITH
A FOCUS ON CLIMATE FROM THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE MULTI MODAL
IN NATURE AND WHICH DELIVER
IMPORTANT CO BENEFITS AS WELL
AS MAKING SERIOUS PROGRESS IN
IMPROVING OUR COURT SURFACE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE ARE SPECIFICALLY
SUPPORTING INVESTMENTS MET MANY
WHICH REFERRED TO BY THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS -- IN KEY COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAMS AVAILABLE TO
CITIES COUNTIES AND REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES SINCE
THESE PROGRAMS ARE REGULARLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED -- AND THERE ARE
MANY PENDING APPLICATIONS --
THEY CAN BE ADDRESSED WITH A
BOOST FROM THIS BUDGET WINDFALL
AND WHICH ARE EMINENTLY
DESERVING OF SUPPORT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE IN ADDITION THE JOINT
REQUEST BEFORE TODAY INCLUDES
OTHER TIMELY AND IMPORTANT
VESTMENTS WHICH WILL TARGET
THE REDUCTION OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS I TO INCLUDE FUNDING
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES --
AN INCREASE I THINK THAT WHICH
A FEW OF THE CALLS REFERRED TO
IN THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM FUNDING -- AND WHICH
WILL ALSO ADDRESS THE DEVELOPER
OF AFFORDABLE INFILL HOUSING
-- OVERALL THE APPROACH
THAT WE'VE COLLABORATED WITH
STAKEHOLDERS SOME OF WHOM WE
HEARD FROM TODAY IN DEVELOPING
THE PROPOSED NEW SUITE OF
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS CLOSELY
ALIGNS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
MULTI FASTER QUIETER EFFORTS
YEAH AND AND WE THINK IN THE
FINAL ANALYSIS DOES SHOW IN THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND APPROPRIATE
MANNER TO ME REDUCTIONS IN
TRANSPORTATION SECTION SECTOR
GHG EMISSIONS WHILE ALSO AS
IMAGINE BEING A VARIETY OF
CRITICAL MOBILITY INVESTMENT
GOALS I ALSO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
OF SERVING AS THE SENATE'S
EX OFFICIO REPRESENTED TO
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION YEAH AND THIS IS
THIS HAPPENS TO BE IN YOUR AREA
WHICH ALSO ENJOYS THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF CTC COMMISSIONERS
AS WELL SO AS WE MOVE FORWARD
I STRONGLY SUPPORT -- A
MEANINGFUL BUDGET AUGMENTATION
IN THIS AREA THANKS I ALSO HAVE
TWO OTHER COMMENTS IF I COULD
YES GO AHEAD SENATOR NEWMAN
-- PRECIADO MINIATURE -- CHAU
GOING IT GELD UNDERLINING MY
COMMENTS WITH EARLY COMING H.
FROM SENATE CORTESE REGARDING
THE THE PROPOSED POSITION
CUTS IN PART A ISSUE THIRTEEN
-- YEAH THE PSYCH TECHS ARE
COVERED BY A COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED AGREEMENT AND HAVE
PERFORMED BY ANY ACCOUNTING
ADMIRABLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
I AND THIS DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THEIR PAY WAS CUT -- IN
MANY CASES THEIR COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED WORKPLACE VISION
FOR REGULARLY JETTISONED AS
A RESULT OF THE DEMANDS OF
PANDEMIC SO YOU KNOW THEY'VE
BEEN SUBJECTED EVEN HIGHER
LEVELS OF PERSONAL RISK THAN
NORMAL YEAH AND WHAT IS YOU
KNOW AN ALREADY CHALLENGING
WORK ENVIRONMENT EVEN WITHOUT
A PANDEMIC I AND IN FACT MANY
OF THESE MANY SUBJECTS INCLUDE
CONTRACTED COATED AS A RESULT
-- AND AND WENT THROUGH THOSE
CHALLENGES CHAU DESPITE THAT
COMMISSION TO THEIR MISSION
THE YOU KNOW THE THAT WE WE WE
RECEIVED VERY RECENTLY AT B.
C.
P.
-- THAT WAS PRESENTED LAST WEEK
TO THIS COMMITTEE THAT PROPOSES
TO LAUGH MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
OF THESE VERY COMMITTED MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND AND
THIS IN THE SERVICE OF OF TO
MIGHT UNDERSTAND YOU'RE FAIRLY
UNPROVEN AND UNTESTED MODEL --
AND I THINK THIS CLEARLY MAKES
NO SENSE IN A MOMENT WHERE
THE NEED TO DELIVER BETTER
AND MORE EFFECTIVE MENTAL
HEALTH MEDICAL SERVICES TO
INMATES HAS NEVER BEEN CLEARER
-- SO WE MAY WANT A RESPONSE
I THINK FROM -- FINANCE OR
THE LA -- ON THIS AREA AND
I'VE GOT ONE OTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN YES
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HI SENATOR THIS IS ALLISON
HEWITT I THINK IT'S FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THAT YOU DON'T APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS THE ADMINISTRATION
IS AWARE OF THE ISSUE AND
LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO RESOLVE
THE ISSUE AND I WOULD NOTE
THAT THAT THE PROPOSAL ITSELF
RESULTED IN THE ADDITION OF
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR POINT
ONE POSITIONS PART OF THAT WAS
A SERIES OF -- -- I COULD HAVE
MANY VERSO SIDE THE PROPOSAL
ANYWAY WHAT WE WHAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TED TED CHEAPER
RESOLUTION RICHARD DONE RIGHT
THE LMAO MOREOVER THE L.
L.
-- WE FOUND WHEN WE ARE
ANALYZING THE PHOTO THERE
ARE A LOT OF GAPS IN THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE NUMBER OF
POSITIONS AND THEIR POTENTIAL
LOCATIONS IT WOULD HAVE ON
HEALTH CARE INCLUDING WHY
EXISTING LEVEL OF HEALTH CARE
IS IN DIVISION ONE ATIONS
ADDITIONAL STAFFING WOULD
HAVE ON CARE -- OKAY THE
RECORDS ON WHICH WE CAN FIND
THAT LEVEL OF STOCK REQUESTED
WAS I HAVE A SUFFICIENT
JUSTIFICATION I SEARCH FOR YOUR
RECOMMENDED REJECTED IN LAS THE
ADMINISTRATION ISN'T PROVIDES
THAT JUSTIFICATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I M.
LASSEN MANAGER WHAT ONE LAST
COMMENT WITH FAILING NEEDS
NO RESPONSE WITH RESPECT TO
PART A ITEM FORTY SEVEN I I
JUST WANTED RE STRONGLY WITH
THE VARIOUS PUBLIC COMMENTS
ON REMOTE CIVIL PROCEEDINGS
DIED IN THE CONDUCT COMMENTERS
VERY CAREFULLY SUMMARIZE
THE ARGUMENTS AGAINST THIS
PROPOSAL -- AND I'LL BE VOTING
TO REJECT IT THANK YOU FOR --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE UNDER
NEWMAN CENTER GROVE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR -- I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT --
ON THESE ITEMS -- I WAS TOLD
IT WAS GOING TO BE A VOTE
ONLY AND WE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
AND THAT WE WERE GONNA ALLOW
COMMENTS UNTIL JUST AT WHEN
SENATOR CORTESE STARTED HIS
COMMENTS -- WHICH I'M GRATEFUL
FOR SO THANK YOU FOR CENTER
PARTIES YOU FOR TAKING THE LEAD
BECAUSE I DID HAVE COMMENTS ON
THIS AND -- I DO WANT TO PUT
ON THE RECORD THAT AND IT IS
VERY FRUSTRATING -- TO BE A
MEMBER OF THE MINORITY PARTY
AND HAVE STAFF NOT AND RECEIVE
ANY INFORMATION ON THESE ITEMS
I THINK THERE'S A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE ITEMS AND WE DON'T
GET INTO LAW LATE YESTERDAY SO
I DO WANNA MAKE THAT COMMENT
BUT SINCE WE ARE ABLE TO
COMMENT I DO WANT TO GO THROUGH
A COUPLE OF ITEMS AND I HAVE
A QUESTION AND I DON'T KNOW IF
FINANCE OR SOMEONE CAN ANSWER
IT BUT -- ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
AND WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEMS DOWN
AND WE'RE GONNA CLOSE THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM DOWN
SO I QUESTION THE REASON WHY
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOCATE AND
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY MCMILLION
TO SEE TURNER SIXTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR FULL TIME
PERMANENT POSITIONS IT FOR
CLOSING THAT DIVISION DOWN
TO SERVE THAT COMMENT ON THAT
ISSUE BECAUSE I'D LIKE SOME
CLARIFICATION AND I'M SORRY
SENER GROUP COULD YOU TELL ME
THE ISSUE NUMBER AGAIN ISSUE
TOO MA'AM IS A MADAM CHAIR AND
AND THAT'S PARTY IT IS PART A
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS
IS ALISON HEWITT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I JUST TO CLARIFY
SENATOR GROVE WHAT WE'RE
WHAT IS IN THE AGENDA IS TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWO POINT NINE
POSITIONS -- WHICH IS JUST
AN INCREMENTAL ADJUSTMENT ON
TOP OF THAT BUDGET FOR THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
OKAY AND THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE IS SLATED
TO CLOSE ON JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE I'M DO
YOU THEY WILL NO LONGER BE
AND IN TAKING YOUTH YOUTH WILL
NO LONGER AT AND BE ASSIGNED
TO THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE IT WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF VERY LIMITED EXCEPTIONS
STARTING JULY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR AND TWO DEEP DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE WILL CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE YOUTH THAT ARE
THERE AND I BELIEVE THE AGENDA
NOTES AND THE NUMBER OF USER
THE ASSUMPTIONS WITH REGARD
TO THE YOUTH AND THE THAT IS
I CONTINUING IN ADDITION AND
AS USE OUR -- FUNCTIONALLY
BEING REALIGNED TO THE COUNTY
STARTING ON JULY FIRST THERE
IS A PROVISION OF COUNTY
PAYMENTS AT PAYMENT THAT WE
NEED TO THE COUNTIES TO YOU
-- SUPPORT RELYING TO USE --
AND NATURAL REFLECTED IN THE
BUDGET OVERALL AS WELL BUT THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
OVERALL THE BUDGET REFLECTS A
TEN POINT ONE MILLION DOLLAR
SAVINGS FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO SO UP FOR THE BUDGET YEAR
I MEAN AGAIN THAT'S REFLECTIVE
OF THE FACT THAT D.
DJ OR DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE WILL ULTIMATELY
BE ACCEPTING FEWER USE
STARTING ON JULY FIRST S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
EXPLANATION THAT MAKES TOTAL
SENSE TO ME AND -- THAT CHANGES
MY NO VOTE TO AN AYE VOTE HEY
-- AND I WISH I WOULD HAVE TO
REALIZE THAT SO AM I MINUTE
DOCUMENT THAT AND MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT ONE I APPRECIATE
THAT AGAIN IT'S JUST BECAUSE
THE LANGUAGE IS CAME IN LAST
LAST NIGHT -- ARE YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON SO MOVING ON TO ISSUE
FIFTEEN -- AND I DON'T KNOW
WHO CAN ANSWER THIS BUT IT'S
THE RE ENTRY FACILITY CRITERION
STATUTORY CHANGES THEIR
STRAIGHTER BILL LANGUAGE BUT
AND THE WAY WE UNDERSTAND THIS
TRAILER BILLING WHICH CDC ARE
WOULD BE ABLE TO PLAY SERIOUS
AND VIOLENT OFFENDERS IN LOS
SECURITY COMMUNITY CORRECTIONAL
RE ENTRY FACILITIES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IS THAT TRUE
AND CORRECT I'M SORRY THIS
IS PART EIGHT ISSUE SIXTEEN
PART EIGHT ISSUES F.
FIFTEEN MADAM CHAIR ONE FIVE
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATOR THIS IS ALLISON TO A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGAINST
THE CRITERIA THAT THE THE
TRAINER BILL LANGUAGE IS JUST
CONFORMING KIND OF EXISTING
LAW WITH CURRENT PRACTICES CDCR
HIDE AUTHORITY UNDER A THREE
JUDGE PANEL AND THAT WAS A
CODIFIED IN STATUTE I'M READY
NO LONGER APPLIES I'M INTO THIS
IS ULTIMATELY JUST CODIFYING
EXISTING PRACTICE OKAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND THEN -- WE'RE
ON A STILL ITEM A.
R.
ISSUE NO PAID SECTION A ITEM
NINETEEN ON THE LONG TERM
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING
-- MY QUESTION I GUESS ON A
COUPLE OF THESE ITEMS WITHIN
CDC ARE IS IS THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY LOOKING FOR -- YOU
KNOW THE LONG TERM PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
PLANNING CLOSURE PLAN WANTING
TO KNOW WHAT THAT LANGUAGE
REALLY LOOKS LIKE BECAUSE WE'RE
I MEAN IT LOOKS LIKE TO ME
THAT REST OF VOTE ON THIS BUT
IT DOESN'T HAVE ANY LANGUAGE
REQUIRING CDCR TO CREATE
OR ADOPT A LONG TERM PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN IN --
THE REQUEST FOR FUNDING SEEMS
SUPPORTABLE BET -- THERE'S
NO LANGUAGE REQUIRING PRISON
CLOSURE PLANS OR YOU KNOW
WAS DISCUSSED AND I GUESS MY
CONCERN IS AS I SAID ON RULES
AS WELL AND ALTHOUGH THAT I
DID HAVE A GREAT CONVERSATION
WITH THE NEW SECRETARY I AM
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT JUST
AUTOMATICALLY CLOSING THESE
INSTITUTIONS WITHOUT US HAVING
ANY INFORMATION ON IT I KNOW
THE TRAILER BUILDING WHICH
IS NOT AVAILABLE YET BUT
CAN SOMEBODY KIND OF ANSWER
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IF WE
ARE GOING TO GET A A A A AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN ON THESE
PARTICULAR FACILITIES OR IS IT
JUST GONNA BE A CLOSURE PLAN OR
IS THERE ANY INDICATION OF WHAT
THAT LANGUAGE WILL LOOK LIKE
MAYBE YOU COULD HAVE THE LA
-- BUT RESPOND TO THAT SIX
ACTUALLY KNOW NEEDLE WITH L.
L.
FROM
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
-- AND THIS IS LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED -- --
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
REQUIRING CDC ARE TO REPORT
AID PLAN FOR MANAGING ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE GOING FORWARD
THAT WOULD BE DUE JANUARY
TEN TWENTY TWENTY TWO -- SAID
MINISTRATION HAS INDICATED THAT
IT -- THERE'S NOT A PLAN TO
COMPLY WITH THAT -- MORE FULLY
COMPLY WITH THAT SUBLIMINAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND SO
I WELL I HAVEN'T SEEN I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE LANGUAGE WOULD
FULLY INTEL MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT -- THIS AB PROPOSAL IS
AN IN LINE WITH THE INTENTION
TO -- HAVE THE LEGEND HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT THAT PROVIDE A PLAN
-- ON -- A LONG TERM PLAN FOR
-- INSURING THAT PRISONS THAT
ARE ULTIMATELY OPERATIONAL
IN THE LONG RUN -- ARE FULLY
ARE PROPERLY MAINTAINED AND
REPAIRED AS NECESSARY THAT HELP
CLARIFY THEM A LITTLE BIT I
THINK YOU FOR THE EXPLANATION
I'M STILL UNCLEAR ROAD ALLOCATE
SO MANY RESOURCES TO YOU KNOW
DOLLARS TAXPAYER DOLLARS IF
WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN TO SEE IF
THOSE FACILITIES ARE GOING TO
BE CLOSED OR NOT AND THERE'S
NO INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN SO
I'M IN AND COULDN'T STAND ON
THAT AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE PLAN IS BEFORE WE
ALLOCATE DOLLARS -- AGAIN -- I
DON'T -- SECTION A.
AS IN APPLE ITEM FORTY SEVEN
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF INDIVIDUALS ON THE PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT CAME IN AND SAID
THAT TRANSLATION SERVICES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT SHOULD BE
IN PERCENT AND NOT REMOTE --
I JUST THINK IT SHOULD BE AN
OPTION I THINK THAT WE LEARNED
A LOT OF THINGS THROUGH CO BID
AND -- YOU KNOW INDIVIDUALS
THAT LIVE IN RURAL AREAS IF
IT WAS EASIER FOR THEM TO GET
ON AND BE IS THE AMBER WEBEX
MEETINGS AND BE BE ABLE TO
-- HAVE THEIR INTERPRETATION
PERSON -- YOU KNOW PROVIDED
TO THEM AND THEY BUT PREFERS
THAT INSTEAD OF DRIVING I MEAN
LIKE FOR INSTANCE THEY'VE SHUT
DOWN COURT HOUSES AND -- ARVIN
LAMONT SHAFTER WASCO AND IT'S
LIKE A FORTY FIVE OR FIFTY
MINUTE DRIVE AND IF YOU LIVE
IN RIDGECREST IT'S A TWO AND
A HALF HOUR DRIVE TO DRIVE TO
A COURT SYSTEM SO PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE THAT TYPE OF RESOURCES FOR
TRANSPORTATION ALLOWING THEM
AN OPTION TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
SOME TYPE OF RULE CONNECTIVITY
FOR FOR -- TRANSLATION SERVICES
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF HISPANIC
POPULATION THAT LIVES ON THE
EAST SIDE OF OUR COUNTY AND
ON THE WEST THE VERY WEST SIDE
OF OUR COUNTY IT'S YOU GOTTA
FIGURE IT'S NINE THOUSAND
SQUARE MILES RIGHT SO AND TO
HAVE THEM HAVE TO DRIVE TO MEET
THE COURT DATE AND MEET WITH
THEIR INTERPRETER I'M YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES TO TWO AND A HALF
HOURS THREE HOURS TO GET TO
COURT IF WE JUST OFF LET THEM
HAVE AN OPTION M.
INSTEAD OF ELIMINATING IT
ALTOGETHER I THINK THAT
WOULD BETTER SERVE A LOT
OF OUR RULE AREAS AND SO
JUST A COMMENT ON THAT
I APOLOGIZE AGAIN I DIDN'T
REALIZE YOU WERE GOING TO
BUILD A COMMENT ON THIS
AND I HAD MADE NOTES --
AND IF WE GO TO I
AM A PART BE SKIS
HEY YOUR GLASSES ARE
WORTHLESS WHEN THEY FOG AT
SEPARATE PIECE OF PAPERS
OKAY SORRY N.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS IN THIS BUDGET I DO
AGREE ON -- I'M NOT GOING TO
GO OVER ALL THOSE WILL BE VOTED
AYE ON THOSE AND AND I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
THAT WERE VERY GOOD IN THIS
BUDGET BUT -- I GUESS ON ISSUE
TEN THE HOMELAND SECURITY GRAB
AT A PROGRAM OF TRANSPARENCY
AGAIN AND IT LOOKS LIKE THAT IT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE SUPPORTABLE FOR REPUBLICANS
BUT WE JUST HAVEN'T SEEN THE
LANGUAGE AND -- WE DON'T KNOW
FILLING WHICH INCLUDES ANYTHING
OBJECTIVE OBJECTIVE ALSO THAT'S
JUST A COMMENT AND BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO SEE THAT
AND THEN -- YOU KNOW I DID HAVE
A COMMENT OR QUESTION -- YOU
KNOW WE'RE OFFERING AN INCREASE
TO CAL TRANS AND A PART OF IT
GOES TO THEIR ADMIN P.
FEES PER MILE IN -- CALIFORNIA
PLEASE MORE ADMIN FEES PER MILE
THAN ALMOST ANY OTHER STATE IN
THE NATION AND I'M JUST CURIOUS
WHY OURS ARE SO HIGH -- THAT
WAS A COMMENTS AND THEN --
SO AGAIN IF YOU GO TO ITEM
TWENTY IN SECTION B.
-- IT'S A RECOMMENDATION OF A
STEAM BECAUSE IT LOOKS AGAIN
LIKE IT WOULD BE SUPPORTABLE
LANGUAGE THAT WITHOUT SEEING
THE LANGUAGE IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE
TO EVEN MAKE A DECISION BUT
WHEN YOU READ THE CHEST OF WHAT
THE INTENT IS IT SEEMS LIKE IT
WOULD BE SUPPORTABLE BUT LIKE
I SAID WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
LANGUAGE AND IT'S REALLY HARD
FOR US TO VOTE ON BILLS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THE LANGUAGE FOR
I'M TRYING TO GET TO THE U.
I.
P.'S SO I APOLOGIZE NO
NO APOLOGIES SENATOR
MANY JUST SKIP OVER THE DMV
I THINK WE ALL BELIEVE THAT'S
A DISASTER IT'S AMAZING TO ME
THAT WE'VE SPENT SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR REAL ID'S ACTUALLY WHEN
A FEW YEARS AGO WHEN THERE IS
A DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATION A
HOT WHITE HOUSE I.
HELP CALIFORNIA GET THEIR FIRST
EXTENSION FOR REAL ID HE'S IN
NOW -- WE'VE INVESTED SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND ANOTHER THREE OR FORTY TWO
MILLION WHICH IS APPROVED FROM
THIS AGENDA FOR FUTURE YEARS
I JUST THINK THAT PEOPLE WILL
GO THROUGH THE NORMAL PROCESS
OF THEIR FIVE YEAR FOR YOUR
ID -- OR DRIVER'S LICENSE
ISSUED -- BEFORE THEY HAVE TO
DO ANY ADDITIONAL STUFF FOR
REAL ID'S SO IT DOESN'T THAT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME
AND I GUESS I I JUST WANT YOU
TO KNOW I'M LOOKING AT IT FROM
A BUSINESS STANDPOINT IF MY
CONTRACT WAS GOING TO RENEW
IN THREE YEARS I WOULDN'T
NEED A FIVE YEAR EXTENSION IN
ORDER TO APPROVE THE CONTRACT
RIGHT IT'S JUST GONNA BE
RENEWED ON A NATIONAL BASIS
SO I HOPE THAT MAKES SENSE AND
AND THEN THAT CAN BE A
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE
THAT SAVES TAXPAYERS SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND THE U.
I FIND I.
E.
R.
I KNOW ALL OF US IN OUR
DISTRICTS HAVE HAD OF A
NUMEROUS PHONE CALLS COME INTO
OUR OFFICE REGARDING YOU AYE
FRIENDS AND YOU KNOW TO THE
CREDIT OF -- DIRECTOR SIGNS ARE
SECRETARY SIGNS SHE HAS DONE
A GREAT JOB IN MAKING SURE AT
LEAST -- THAT WE HAVE ACCESS
TO PEOPLE TO HELP US ADDRESS
THESE YOU I BENEFITS THAT ARE
BEING PAID OUT TO INDIVIDUALS
THAT RIGHTFULLY DESERVE THEM
OF MY CONCERN IS IS THAT
ITEM FORTY ONE -- WILL REDUCE
THE STAFF AT THE E.
D.
T.
AND I GUESS MY QUESTION IS IS
THAT IS THAT A GOOD IDEA WELL
WE STILL HAVE A HUGE BACKLOG
AND I WOULD I KNOW SHE'S NOT
ON THE LINE BUT I WOULD REALLY
BE INTERESTED IN DIRECTOR SIGNS
IS AN OPINION ON THE REDUCED
REDUCTION OF THE STAFF OR IF
ANYBODY AND THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION HAS HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH HER TO SEE
WHAT HER THOUGHTS WERE ON THE
REDUCTION OF THE STAFF BEFORE
WE AN MAKE THAT DECISION TO
TO REDUCE THAT AM LANGUAGE FOR
THOSE EMPLOYEES UP A CAN WE
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE LA -- OF COMMON IF
YOU WANT THE FORMER FINANCE
YES MA'AM DANIELLE'S BRANDON
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I AM I TOO AM LOOKING FOR MY
NOTES ON THE SPECIFIC ITEMS
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT EDT
RECEIVES A BASE GRANTS THAT IS
-- BASED ON IT THAT IS FUNDING
BASED ON THE ANTICIPATED LEVEL
OF UNEMPLOYMENT THESE FUNDS
CAN'T COVER OTHER COSTS -- AND
THEREFORE SINCE THE ANTICIPATED
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS GOING
DOWN THESE RESOURCES ARE GOING
DOWN AND THAT IS THAT WAY
WITH REGARD TO THE WORK WE DO
HAVE THE PROPOSAL AT FOR TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX POINT THREE
MILLION TO HELP EDT ADDRESS
THAT BACK -- AND -- PERSPECTIVE
WORKLOAD THAT IS NOT COVERED
BY THAT FEDERAL THESE GRANTS
SO I'M JUST CURIOUS YOU HAVE A
MECHANISM TO ADDRESS DOWN BUT
NOT IN A MECHANISM TO ADJUST
UP WHAT HAPPENS IF THERE IS --
ANOTHER CODE THAT OPERATE IN
WE HAVE TO ADJUST IS THERE A
MECHANISM IN PLACE TO ADJUST
UP FOR STAFFING LEVELS OR JUST
DOWN YES SENATOR THERE IS --
THE ITEMS IN THE BUDGET FOR A
REVISION OF THESE ITEMS BOTH
IN OCTOBER AND IN MAY BOTH IN
THE CURRENT YEAR AND BUDGET
YEAR SO IT'S SOME FOR SOME
REASON THESE PROJECTIONS CHANGE
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR EDT WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
THOSE ADJUSTMENTS OKAY GOOD
THAT'S GREAT NEWS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT INFORMATION
I DID THE LAST ITEM I WANT
TO SAY IS LIKE I SAID THERE'S
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS IN THIS
BUDGET THERE REALLY ARE SOME
THERE ARE SOME THINGS I HAVE
QUESTIONS ON THAT WE COULD
SUPPORT AND PROVIDE BI PARTISAN
SUPPORT IF WE JUST HAD THE
LANGUAGE TO LOOK OUT BECAUSE
THE INTENT OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN
LIKE I SAID IT'S SOMETHING
THAT SUPPORTABLE BUT I WANT TO
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR AND THE
GOVERNOR STAFF AND ANYBODY ELSE
THAT WAS ENGAGED IN ITEM FORTY
TWO TO ALLOW -- FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN JOINT
A GENERAL FUND ONE TIME MANY
TO MAKE AN ESTIMATED INTEREST
PAYMENT ON THE U.
I TRUST FUND WE
ALL KNOW THAT THE E.
D.
R.
THE IMPLEMENT OF THE LIMITS
OF HARTMAN HAS -- INCURRED
SUBSTANTIAL FRAUD AN INMATE
FRAUD IS ESTIMATED AT TWO
BILLION AND OTHER OUTSOURCE
FRAUD IS RESPONSIBLE TO THAT
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS IS COMPLETELY COVERED BY
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE SMALL
BUSINESS AND LARGE THAT HAVE
-- HAD A TREMENDOUS LOSS IN
REVENUE IF YOU THINK ABOUT OUR
RESTAURANTS ARE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE HOTEL INDUSTRIES
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO --
GENERATE REVENUE -- OVER THE
LAST TWENTY TWENTY YEAR BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC CAN BE DECLARED
NONESSENTIAL OR TRAVEL NOT
WORKING SEAT STAY IN HOTELS
OR RESORTS OR THINGS LIKE THAT
SO I APPRECIATE YOU GUYS VERY
MUCH AT LEAST COVERING THAT
FIRST PAYMENT I'M HOPING WE CAN
GET TO A PLACE NEXT YEAR WHERE
AND I KNOW YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO COVER THE WHOLE THIRTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS OF ESTIMATED AN
OVERDRAFT IN THE U.
I FIND TO THE TRUST FUND IT
MAY BE THE STATE COULD STEP
UP AND HELP EMPLOYERS WHICH IS
THE AT THE FRAUD AMOUNT WHICH
IS RIGHT NOW LOOKING BETWEEN
ELEVEN AND FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT BECAUSE THIS
DOES FALL ON THE BACKS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF TIME TO PREPARE -- AT
THE END OF THE YEAR JANUARY
THE FIRST OR SECOND WEEK IN
JANUARY WE GET IT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND BUSINESSES GET
A BILL THAT BILL CAN EQUAL
ANYWHERE FROM FIFTY THOUSAND TO
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND AN
EVEN HIGHER AND IT'S DUE IN TEN
DAYS AND TO COME UP WITH SOME
TYPE OF THAT TYPE OF REVENUE
IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR SOME
BUSINESSES SO DEFINITELY I
JUST WANNA GIVE YOU BIG KUDOS
AND A BIG THANK YOU FOR AT
LEAST MAKING THIS FIRST PAYMENT
ESPECIALLY AFTER WE COME OUT OF
THIS TWENTY TWENTY -- PANDEMIC
THANK YOU
SENATOR GROUP AND I M.
I'M REMINDED THAT THE ACTUAL
IT IS COMMON TO PUT A PLACE
HOLDER OFFER LANGUAGE OF THE
ACTUAL TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WILL COME BACK TO THE FULL
BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR VOTE
THAT'S RIGHT MA'AM I APPRECIATE
THAT I FORGOT ABOUT THAT SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY --
ALL RIGHT AND I I WANT TO MAKE
A COUPLE OF MARKS ON THE THE
LABOR PORTION JUST OVERALL
-- WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PART
OF A IS SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
DEAR TO ME I APPRECIATE THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROVIDED
-- OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR WORKFORCE AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS -- THIS IS DEFINITELY
A HISTORIC LEVEL OF INVESTMENT
UP WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE FUNDS HAVE STANDARDS
THAT THEY HAVE CRITERIA THAT
LEAD TO GOOD PAYING JOBS THE
QUALITY TRAINING OUR HIGH ROAD
INVESTMENTS MUST GET TO THE
PEOPLE IN THE STATE THAT NEED
IT THE MOST -- I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING ON THESE PROPOSALS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE
OUGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS ACCOUNTABILITY THAT THERE'S
TRANSPARENCY WITH THE USE OF
THESE FUNDS AND THAT WE ARE
FOLLOWING INDIVIDUALS INTO THE
LABOR MARKET WITH THE WITH THE
JOB AND TO BE ABLE TO JUDGE
AND EVALUATE HOW THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE DOING SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS ALSO ARE
COORDINATED I DO BELIEVE AND
I AGREE WITH THIS THAT THEY'RE
COORDINATED UNDER ONE VISION
A UNIFIED STRUCTURE AND A PLAN
THAT MAKES SENSE -- FOR ALL OF
THEM TOGETHER SO WITH THAT --
SEEN BUT NO MARK COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR -- IT IS AS IS MR.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT WERE THE
TOP PART EIGHT ISSUED TO YES
YOU'RE MOVING THAT TO A I YES
MA'AM AND THEN WORK THEN TAKING
IT OFF OF -- THE LIST OF THE
NOBLES YES MA'AM OKAY THANK YOU
BECAUSE OF THE EXPLANATION I
APPRECIATE THAT MA'AM GOOD OKAY
SO NOW WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
VOTE IN IN THE FOLLOWING -- --
CATEGORIES IN PART A THE FIRST
VOTE WILL BE ON THESE ISSUES
ONE TWO FIVE EIGHT THROUGH
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREE THROUGH THIRTY SIX FORTY
THROUGH FORTY SIX FORTY EIGHT
TO FIFTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT SIXTY
THROUGH SIXTY THREE SIXTY FIVE
THROUGH SIXTY EIGHT SEVENTY
AND SEVENTY ONE DO WE HAVE OH
EIGHT AND PART B.
EXCUSE ME AND PART B.
IT SHOES THREE TO SEVEN IF
YOU NINE IT SHOES ELEVEN
THROUGH FOURTEEN IS SHE SIXTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO THROUGH
TWENTY NINE THIRTY TWO THIRTY
SIX THROUGH FORTY AND FORTY TWO
TWO FIFTY EIGHT CAN I HAVE A
MOTION ON THESE ISSUES PLEASE
MOVED BY SENATOR GROVE BUT THE
ISSUES THESE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR GROUP WILL
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS ARE ALSO YES HI
THERE ALSO HI SENATOR GROWTH HI
CENTER GROVE HI SENATOR CORTEZ
HE SENATOR CORTEZ THE AYE
SENATOR NEWMAN SENATOR NEWMAN
AYE AYES FOR NOS ZERO K.
ISSUES THAT THE MOTION WAS
PASSES THE SECOND SET OF BOATS
THAT WE ARE TAKING IN PART A
WE ARE TAKING UP ISSUES THREE
SEVEN NO FIFTEEN FORTY SEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN AND SIXTY NINE
IN PART BE WE ARE TAKEN UP
ISSUES EIGHT FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THIRTY THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE AND
FORTY ONE CAN WE PLEASE HAVE
A MOTION ON THESE ISSUES SOME
OF MOVED BY SENATOR NEWMAN
IS ISSUES HAVE BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER AND NEWMAN WILL
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR RAZA HI SENATOR ALSO
HI SENATOR GROWTH NO CENTER
GROVE NO CENTER CORTESE CENTER
CORTESE HI SENATOR NEWMAN HI
THERE NEWMAN HI GUYS THREE
NOS ONE OUR MOTION PASSES
AND FINALLY IN THE THIRD SET
OF VOTES IN THE FINAL SET OF
VOTES WE HAVE PART A ISSUES
FOUR SIX SEVENTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO THIRTY SEVEN TO
THIRTY NINE FIFTY NINE SIXTY
FOUR AND SEVENTY TWO IN PART
BE WE'RE TAKING UP ISSUES
ONE AND TO A DONATED OKAY ONE
AND TWO TEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THIRTY THREE AND FIFTY NINE
WE HAVE A A MOTION ON THESE
ISSUES SOME OF CENTER GROVE
THE MOVE BY SENATOR GROW WELL
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CENTERED ARE ALSO I
CENTER DORADO HI SENATOR GROW
NOT VOTING CENTER GROVE NOT
VOTING SENATOR CORTESE ALL
RIGHT SENATOR CORTEZ HE I AND
SENATOR NEWMAN SENATOR NEWMAN
HI GUYS THREE NOS ZERO ONE NO
VOTING THE AYES HAVE IT THE
MOTION PASSES -- COLLEAGUES
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO CHAIR
THIS COMMITTEE THIS YEAR
AND TO WORK ON CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET IS NOTHING THAT IS MORE
IMPACTFUL -- AND AN EXPRESSION
OF OUR VALUES AND PRIORITIES
WE BEGAN WE BEGAN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IN THE GROUPS OF A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY AND LOSS WE WERE
FOCUSED ON RECOVERY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY ON A RECOVERY THE
CHALLENGED AND TRANSFORMED
THE INEQUITIES IN OUR STATE
WE WE DID NOT WANT TO RETURN
TO NORMAL AS WE CLOSE OUT OUR
COULD SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY I WANT
TO FIRST THANK OUR SUB FIVE
CONSULTANTS FOR COMMITTEE YOUR
TALENT -- YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS
AND YOUR TIME YOUR MANY MANY
LONG HOURS AND DEFINITELY
NOT ENOUGH SLEEP THROUGH THIS
WORK WE COULDN'T DO IT WITHOUT
YOU AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
DIFFERENCE YOU ARE MAKING IN
THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO THIS THESE
ISSUES -- IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
SPENDING THURSDAY AFTERNOONS
WITH YOU I AM GRATEFUL FOR ALL
THOSE WHO SPENT THOSE HOURS
ON PUBLIC COMMENT A COLLIE
MAN MAKING YOUR VOICES HEARD I
HOPE YOU BELIEVE US IT MATTERS
AND IT MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR YOUR EXPERTISE ON
EVERY SUBJECT NO MATTER HOW
COMPLICATED OR DIFFICULT THE
PROPOSALS WE WORK DONE THIS
YEAR WILL BRING ABOUT CHANGE
IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM OUR
INVESTMENTS ARE GOING TO HELP
HEAL TRAUMA IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND AT THE SAME TIME CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES WE'VE BEEN
FOCUSED ON VIOLENCE PREVENTION
ON CULTURALLY GROUNDED SUPPORT
SYSTEMS THAT ARE ACCESSIBLE
TO ALL VICTIMS AND ON PATHWAYS
WERE INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
TO LEAD FULL AND MEANINGFUL
LIVES RECOGNIZING THE IMMENSE
STRAIN ON OUR COURTS AND THE
EFFECT THIS HAS ON ACCESS TO
JUSTICE WE'VE SUPPORTED AND
SHAPE PROPOSALS FOR LEGAL
AID AND EVICTION PROTECTIONS
AND ALSO PROFESSIONALS THAT
REPRESENT THE MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN IN OUR STATE IN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE WE DID NOT TAKE
FOR GRANTED THE DISPARITIES
THAT EXIST IN THE HALLS
OF OUR COURT ROOMS THESE
DISPARITIES WILL BE EXACERBATED
BY TECHNOLOGY UNLESS WE HAVE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE CALIFORNIA
WORKERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
OUR ECONOMY AND THEY DESERVE
TO SHARE IN THE FINANCIAL
SUCCESS OF THE INDUSTRIES
THEY WORK IN WE STARTED THIS
YEAR WITH AN EMPLOYMENT SYSTEM
THAT LEFT LAID OFF WORKERS
WITHOUT THE PROTECTIONS THEY
NEED THEY WERE STRUGGLING
JUST TO GET THE BENEFITS DUE
TO THEM THE PANDEMIC HAS SHED
NEW LIGHT ON OUR WORKPLACES
INCLUDING PERVASIVE WAGE
THEFT DANGEROUS AND UNHEALTHY
WORKING CONDITIONS LACK OF
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND
TIME OFF ONE SIX THE RIGHT
TO GET PAID A DIGNIFIED WAGE
OF FAMILY SUSTAINING WAGE
NOT A POVERTY WAGE WE HAVE
PRIORITIZED ESSENTIAL WORKERS
IN A RECOVERY THAT WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT
THEIR SKILLS AND SACRIFICES
AND WE HAVE MADE SURE THEY
GET THEIR JOBS BACK OUR FOCUS
ON WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT HAS
CENTERED ON A CLEAR COMMITMENT
TO CREATING GOOD PAYING JOBS
GREEN JOBS TO TACKLE CLIMATE
CHANGE AND INEFFECTIVE JUST
MODEL FOR A NEW ECONOMY THE
REWARDS HIGHROAD PARTNERSHIPS
WITH EMPLOYERS TO RESPECT
THEIR WORKERS PROVIDE QUALITY
TRAINING APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THE INCLUSION OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND CREATING GOOD
PAYING JOBS THESE INVESTMENTS
WILL SHAPE LITERALLY WHAT ARE
STATE LOOKS LIKE IN TEN TWENTY
MAYBE EVEN FIFTY YEARS FROM
NOW WHO WOULD HAVE IMAGINED
THAT AFTER A YEAR OF PAINFUL
BUDGET DECISIONS WE WOULD
TODAY HAVE A SEVENTY SIX
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS THIS
IS INCREDIBLE BUT IT ALSO IS
A CHALLENGING RESPONSIBILITY
SO WE LOOK TO REMEDY THE PAST
WILL BUILD ON THE STRENGTH OF
OUR REALLY GREAT STATE THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR ALL
OF YOUR WORK HAVE A GOOD DAY